All right people,
this is it.
I feel like this is a lifetime coming.
Uh,
we are going to be deleting our
patrion page during this live stream.
Uh, for those of you that
don't know, Patrion, uh,
has been the number one source of funding
for us since we went independent back
in June of 2016. That's when I started
my independent production company.
Uh, that's when we fully took the
reigns of this company in this show.
I have no boss.
I am my boss.
I guess I am the boss around
here for better or worse. Uh,
we've built a great little production
company. We've got full timers,
we've got part timers, we
pay for everyone's insurance
and dental and blah, blah,
blah.
We treat all of our employees great.
I think we've built a
really great show here. Uh,
I think fan funding was the key to
making this thing truly successful. Uh,
the fact that I can make whatever decision
I think is right for the show and the
business, the fact that I've
been able to take sort of my,
my small government principles and my,
my refound let's say belief in,
in capitalism and business,
uh,
and apply it to the things that I'm
doing behind the scenes as well as the
issues that I'm talking about
on air in front of you guys.
The last couple years have
just been amazing. We've,
the show is just absolutely blown up.
We're about to cross a million subscribers
on youtube despite often people being
unsubscribed from the youtube channel.
Uh,
the audio podcast is basically bigger
than the youtube channel at this point.
I think the things that we've been talking
about over the last couple of years
have been incredibly relevant
and seemingly every day
now become more relevant.
Uh,
I mean,
even the fact that this is all going
down on patrion related to freedom of
speech,
and it was because of them kicking off
Carl Benjamin Sargon and for cod who's
been in this very studio that we built.
And I bought this house because of Patrion
or because of in large part because
of the donations you guys have been
making on Patrion over the last couple of
years. Um, it seems so fitting that
we're going to finally do this.
So I know there's a lot of eyeballs on
this and I know there's a lot of eyeballs
in the media on this. I know
their employees at patrion
watching this right now.
How are you guys?
Uh,
I know there's big shots at Google and
Facebook watching and the rest of it and
I think that, uh, look, Sam Harris
left patrion because of this. Uh,
Jordan is deleting Jordan Peterson is
deleting his patrion account today.
He may have done it already.
He's in Switzerland right now.
We spoke on the phone briefly.
We were going to possibly
a Skype him in and on this,
I don't think it's going to happen cause
it's like three in the morning there,
but who knows,
maybe some surprises will happen over
the course of the next two hours. Um,
but this seems like just the next obvious
step in everything that's been going
on here.
I just think that at some point us the
people have to push back against these
tech companies. You can't keep
infringing on freedom of expression. Yes,
they can do whatever they
want as private companies.
And there's some issue whether these
platforms are now becoming, uh, the,
the true public space of the future.
And does that have,
what's the relationship between,
uh,
that entity as a platform that we can
all communicate on and the government,
we can discuss that until the,
the nth degree.
I am trying to apply the same principles
that I apply consistently at everything
else here. I didn't ask the government to
come in and demand but gone to for cod,
stay on Patrion or on
Twitter or anywhere else.
I didn't ask the government
to get involved in and stop
this person from getting
banned or that person from getting banned.
I think these Banning's or a problem,
you guys know my policy on gatekeeping.
I'd rather much wider gates,
generally speaking,
as long as people are following
the laws of the United States.
And we don't have hate speech laws and
people are allowed to say mean things and
it's scary sometimes,
but I would much rather have that than
have all sorts of voices who are a little
outside of mainstream be shut down.
Especially because in these days it's
not just the really bad voices that,
um,
that maybe shouldn't be ignored.
Perhaps it's that it's coming
for sort of everybody. Um,
so I'm going to discuss a
whole bunch of things here. Uh,
we are going to be deleting the
Patrion page live. So Aaron,
can you throw into the live shot
of the computer that is right here.
Uh,
right now,
despite for the last month mean emailing
all my patrons doing live streams,
tweeting the hell out of this thing,
posting it on Facebook,
posting it on Instagram,
and God knows what else I've been doing.
As you can see right now,
right now we've got almost 1800 patrons
that still remain in there for about
$10,000 a month. Now, I don't
think, all right, aren't you?
Come back to me for a second.
I don't think a normal person
running a business would say, oh,
can I take what was a,
when we started this thing about a month
ago when we started announcing we were
going to leave, uh, or at least when
the, when the Carl Benjamin thing popped,
I don't think a normal
businessmen is like, oh,
can I just get rid of 70% of my company's
revenue and we'll see what happens.
But I just felt like it was just enough
and I had faith that you guys were going
to come with me on this adventure.
Uh,
so I am thrilled to say that
we have done really nicely,
we haven't made up all the Patriot
on money, but we've done really,
really nicely@daverubin.com slash donate
so we are going to use this live stream
for one more round of fundraising to
really, uh, just blow that thing up.
So it's Dave ruben.com/donate if you
donate while I'm live right now for $5 and
above, uh, are going to
give you a live shout out.
And I've got a trusty iPad here and a team
of dedicated professionals in the, uh,
in the control room over there. If
you donate via paypal, via stripe,
whatever it is at Dave Rubin
dotcoms there's no way I'm
going to give you a live
shout out.
If you donate $25 or more per month,
you're gonna get the
Rubin report select shirt.
Now this is the select shirt that are
only our patrons had certain levels were
getting.
These will never be printed again.
We've got a couple boxes on the left
because they were printed patrion only
obviously we're never
going to print them again.
So these are the last
couple that we've got left.
I think we've got about
a hundred of them left.
Let's see if we can move some of these.
You will get one of these.
You're going to a, you make the
donation, then you send us your size.
We've got your email,
we'll take good carrier.
And if you donate 50 or more monthly,
I am going to sign a Ruben report,
official Mug that will never be printed
again either because it's the select
member mug.
I'm going to sign that for you right here,
live on air and we're going to send it
to you and you guys will ensure that the
show remains completely
independent. And uh, and as I said,
I've had a whole bunch
of offers from networks,
some that I would consider working with.
I've had all sorts of offers
to do more ads on the show.
I've had every which way that you
can think of funding something.
I've had offers,
we've had other people offer us big money.
I like doing it this way. I
think it's great. I'm psyched.
I'm happy. I'm content.
I want to keep growing.
There's so many good things happening
over the course of the next year. Uh,
in terms of we're continuing the tour
with Jordan Peterson in May and June.
We're going to hit all sorts of
countries in Europe and do that again in
February for a couple of weeks. I'll be
in Australia. We're bouncing all over the,
all over the country.
Uh,
in April we're considering I have an
offer to do a full month of Reuben reports
on the road all over the United States.
I have to make sure that I actually can
do it because the other thing is that
I'm writing a book right now,
which I've been writing forever and my
due date to have the book done is uh,
August 1st.
So I got a,
I got a lot going on and I'm also
supposed to do a show and I've been doing
standup again and all that good stuff.
Um, so, uh, there's a lot happening here,
but I want to keep this momentum going.
Also,
the key to this whole thing is that
Jordan and I also are working on a new
platform.
So there's a limit to the amount that
I can talk about this specifically for
legal reasons and,
and I can't give away all the secrets
and the keys to the kingdom just yet.
We're working on another platform.
There are huge,
huge questions related to how do we want
this platform to function and should
this be all, you know, should
it be monetized through Crypto,
should we be doing torrent video streaming
and how do we fully protect it so
that not so that we can't, we don't
have to worry about payment processors,
we don't have to worry about a tech
companies taking us down and all of those
things. As crazy as that is, right? All
I'm doing here is exercising free speech.
I like interviewing people and now and
enjoy having good conversation and all
that stuff, but we do have to
think about all these things.
So Jordan and I are working on that.
There is a company formed with,
so there's all sorts of legal things
that have to be dealt with in the rest of
that. We are working on that. This,
what I'm doing today is just
step one of all of that.
So step one for me was let's
get off patrion and let's
move everybody so that we
can fund everybody on our site. Whatever
we do after this. By the way, if you're,
if you're going to jump over today,
ruben.com/donate and you do the monthly
credit card thing over there and paypal,
we're gonna be able to fold that into the
new thing because we don't want people
to have to sign up for a zillion things
and cancel a zillion things and all that.
Because as you can see by the 2000 people
that haven't cancelled patrion and yet
people forget to do things right.
So it's like I could just not delete
patrion right now and just keep cashing in
on these people, but I'm
obviously not gonna do that.
Um, so okay, here we go. Oh,
by the way. So I'm going to be answering
questions so you can answer questions.
You can ask questions in super chat. I'm
happy to take some questions there. Uh,
I'm obviously going to be given some
prime real estate right now to people that
are the current patrons who are asking
questions and I just want to say beyond
anything else. And then I'll tell you
some other fun stuff. I am beyond, beyond,
beyond humbled and honored.
And
I,
uh,
I'm a better person because of
this whole adventure. It is.
I can't describe to you what it is like
to have people all over the world just
believe in you doing something.
And I'm just doing what I think is right.
That really is it.
I'm some guy doing what I think is right.
It's not any more magical than that.
And for whatever reason,
we live in a weird time,
especially in the west,
or especially let's say in
the United States where we,
we are in the freest country,
in the history of the world right now.
This evil patriarchy that we
live in is the freest place ever.
And people are afraid
to say what they think.
They're afraid to stand up and fight for
what they believe in and all this stuff.
And I just, I don't know what's wrong
with me, but I just can't not do it. So,
so here I am,
I'm just drawn a line in the sand and I'm,
I'm doing what I think is right and I'm,
and I'm reaping the rewards for it.
And I'm incredibly humbled by that. So
I thank you guys. Truly. So again, okay,
just one more, uh, one more
reset on the radio here. Uh,
if you, if you donate $5 and
above, uh, during this live stream,
I'm going to give you a live shout
out 25 bucks or above monthly.
You're getting the Rubin report shirt
that will never be printed again. People,
the select members shirt that'll
never be printed again. $50 or above.
You're going to get the shirt
and you're going to get the mug.
And I'm going to sign the Mug for you
right here. I've got a trustee sharpie.
Okay. And now, just to sweeten the deal,
I sent out one of the Rubin report team
members to pick up an unopened bottle of
patroned. Okay. We just
pick this thing up.
I am opening it for the first time and
I don't know exactly what we're going to
do with this. When we
originally launched on, uh,
on Patrion back in 2016,
we were trying to figure
out fun ways to raise funds.
And one of the things I did was I think
for every thousand bucks we raised
during a live stream, I did a
shot. And if I'm not mistaken,
within like an hour and a half, I had
done like five shots. I was wasted.
I think I ended up doing something
like seven shots. It was not pretty,
it was not good.
And I'm older now and I'm wiser and
I don't think I can do that level,
but I've got an unopened bottle of patrol
and as you can see here are and go to
the other screen so I can show them this
thing is unaltered, untouched, okay.
And uh, and I've got a trustee shot
glass, this shot glass, by the way,
you can't see anything on it right now.
Unfortunately.
I got this at universal studios.
It used to have a decepticon logo on it,
which I really loved and I don't know
what happened to the decepticon let it go.
But I will do a shot in
honor of sound waves.
So I don't know exactly what
I'm going to make the, the, uh,
the marks for when going to do
shots. But impress me, you know,
do throw out something good
on just on superchat we are,
we're trying to raise some funds here
and then we're going to delete this thing
at the end. And I hear, I
haven't, I'm going to have some
chili for dinner, so. Okay.
So let me ask some questions or a couple
shout outs. Quick to Devin, Andrew, Eric,
Jeff and Travis. Thank
you guys. Uh, okay. Uh,
on superchat go. Reuben, go.
I'll do it. All right. Thank you.
Good luck Dave and team wishing you
the best day of here's to the future.
We're here to support you.
A CBD American Shaman of San Antonio.
I do, you know, every now
and again I'll do a little,
a little if I got like
an ache or something.
I think I mentioned this the other day.
Take a little CBD cream and a,
I do like the CBD. Dave, thanks for
all the great videos. I'm a size large.
Um, I'll debate tomorrow
about the government shut.
I'm in a debate tomorrow about the
government shutdown. Wish me luck.
Good luck to Ya. Um, let's
see, uh, for free speech.
What is your opinion on the daily
wire and do you wish to join? Um,
well first off, I think the
daily wire is doing great stuff.
I obviously have some disagreements
with the Conservatives on a couple of
different things. Uh, I have
some disagreements with band.
I've discussed those disagreements right
here related to to some gay issues and
to abortion and to death penalty
and a bunch of other things.
But I think Ben is a decent guy and
I think despite our differences,
we want to live in the
same country together.
We've had a good time on stage together
last month at one of the Jordan Peterson
events here in la, I brought Ben out
on stage. The crowd went bananas.
He brought me, you know, there
we have this gay cake debate.
So he brought me a little
cupcake. Everyone went crazy
and it was just wonderful.
Thousands of people screaming
and it's like, you know,
then I look on Twitter and it's like the
usual is the tolerant, Progressive Joe.
Look at the homophobic gay
guy on spirits together.
It's like grow up you children. What
planets do you want to live on? Um, okay,
so, uh, go Reuben, go. We
did that one. Uh, hey Dave,
I just want to say thank you for standing
on principle, no matter the cost.
You've inspired my own channel from the
start and I'm grateful. That's awesome.
I want a zillion people to do
this. I don't need to, you know,
I'm doing interviews,
a lot of people do interviews,
but it's like more and more and more.
Let's get a little braver here.
Let's keep telling people what we think.
We got a lot of bad people right now
that are willing to shout everybody down
and d platform everybody and,
and scream,
you're racist and you're a bigot
and all this other nonsense.
They're very brave right now.
And I see a lot of good
people that are not brave and,
and that's part of the problem at the
moment. And uh, we were going to fix that.
Uh, so reminder, we're just raising some
funds right now here. You know what if a,
I'll do a shot for eh, at the net
when we hit 500 bucks on super chat.
I'll do a shot. How about something
like that or a, you know, let's get,
we really want to get people over to
[inaudible] dot com slash donate though
because we're trying to,
we just want to make sure we have a good
monthly budget so we can grow the show.
We can continue to do the things
that we're doing and all that.
So the more of you that jump
over there, the better. Um, guys,
if we're getting shout outs and mugs,
I'm not seeing it on here,
so maybe we're not live on here. I'm
not sure if anything's not being edited.
So let, so let me know
about that guys. Um,
on Patrion I'm behind free speech end you,
Dave and Jordan,
thank you for all your hard work on
behalf of free people everywhere on my way
over to Dave's new site to donate
there in place of Patrion much love and
success to you both in 2019. Thank you
very much. Uh, another one on page on out,
on Patrion on as a direct owner.
Thanks a lot.
You know, the other part
of this is, um, you know,
nobody from Patriot has reached out to me.
Uh,
Jack Conti who sat in that chair and
said that you wouldn't get kicked off
Patrion for speech.
You would only get kicked off for
manifest the observable behavior,
which is a term that I think he made up,
which has the acronym mob mob
manifest observable behaviors.
So only a mob could kick you off
cause you can't make shit up.
I mean that's completely bananas.
Um,
I just realized that I just don't
trust them. I, and it's like, look,
do I trust Google? Do I trust youtube
to, do we trust any of these things?
Not really.
But I think that the experiment of
Patrion was sort of small enough that I
wanted to make a move on this. And as I've
said in some of the other livestreams,
look,
I have friends and people that I have
nothing but total respect for like Bret
Weinstein and column Moriarty who
are staying on Patrion right now.
And maybe they'll be able to fight on
the inside and get them to change their
terms of service.
Even though they didn't even follow
their own terms of service because in the
Patriot, in terms of service, they said,
these are the things you're not
allowed to say on our platform. Uh,
Carl Benjamin did not say the n
word on their platform. He said it,
he didn't even say it on
his own youtube channel.
He said it on someone else's
youtube channel 10 months ago. Um,
and he didn't even use the n word
as a racially pejorative term.
He used it because he
was using the language,
perhaps slightly sloppily of the alt
right against them. That's the point.
This guy debates all right people,
he is not a racist.
And I also think it's
sort of fitting that, um,
that this all sort of boils down to to
Carl. Not to make it too much about him,
but when I was having my wake up when I
was a full on lefty and I was on TYT and
I don't know, I guess I had a
lobectomy, you're saying, um,
when I was part of that thing,
when I started waking up to what was
going on related to free speech and the
authoritarianism that had
permeated throughout the
left and, and this, this, uh,
this really awful social justice monster
that I think now everybody obviously
sees. And I guess I happened to be one
of the first people that were seeing it.
When, when I started talking
about everybody said,
you got to talk to Carl Benjamin, you
gotta talk to this Guy Sargon of Akkad.
So it seems sort of fitting that the first
guy that I talked to online about all
this was the one who got booted.
That's now causing me to leave this.
And we're just taking control of our desks
any and all that good stuff. Shout outs
to Kyle, to Joshua, to Nolan, to Noah,
and to call. And thank you. Uh,
one small step for intellectual is one
giant leap for the intellectual dark web.
Hashtag shots of freedom,
uh,
watching you at Jordan at the Tabernacle
here in Atlanta. You guys were awesome.
Keep it up. Love you buddy. That
was actually one of my favorite shows,
uh,
because it was Jordan's birthday and uh,
the crowd is just fantastic.
People spontaneously sung happy birthday
to him. We brought him out, you know,
he won't eat cake. Um,
so we brought him out
a raw steak with the, with
the candle in it. It was,
it was just a blast though and the crowd
was just great and we had to just a
great city, a way to stand up
for your principles. Thank you.
Thanks for standing up for liberty.
Dave.
Look forward to seeing you
and Jordan in New Zealand. Um,
I am not going to be in New Zealand.
I can't do the New Zealand leg.
I'm going to leave Australia a little
bit early. I got one week of the year.
My family, everybody, folks, brother,
sister, nieces, nephews, everybody.
We all get together for one
week in an undisclosed location.
And that's the one week we do it.
And,
and for all the goodness
that's going on and at,
for as much as I would love to be in,
in New Zealand and eat some of
that good New Zealand lamb, uh,
I'm not going to be, I'm not going to
be there for that. I'm sorry about that.
But I, I promise I will get back there
at some point. Trust me, it sucks.
It's one of the places
that I haven't been,
that I would love to get to and
I will get there at some point.
I promise you that.
Shout out to Patrick and a reminder guys,
you can get shirts 25 bucks monthly.
Uh,
you're getting a shirt
or Ruben report shirt.
It is a select member shirt by the way,
that we'll never be printed again.
50 bucks. I'm signing mugs. People don't
make me leave these mugs in this room.
I've got to get rid of, I got to move
product. You know what I'm saying? Uh,
let's see.
Why have you not had Michael mcwhorter
mcwhorter or Glenn Lowry on the show?
I don't know why it's happening. I think
we'd been in touch with Lowery at least.
Um, let me, let me look into that.
Thanks for standing up for free speech.
Good luck Dave. Okay, so here
we go. I am going to, uh,
first I'm going to open up the patrol. So
make me an offer I can't refuse. I mean,
that's what I'm saying.
People go over to Dave rubin.com/and
it make me an offer I can't refuse.
I'll do a shot at patroned in
honor of leaving Patrion Foria. Uh,
by the way, I'm having a
crazy day over here, uh,
not only just with the energy
around this thing. Um, but I, uh,
I've shot three shows already today, which
were, which were really something. Um,
I don't even want to give everything away,
so we've got a great show tomorrow that
I taped the first thing this morning. Uh,
I'll leave it up to,
to mystery at the moment,
but I'd really take three great
shows today. Um, and uh, all right,
so I am opening this bad boy.
It is now open.
There we go. Smells like Tequila.
Oh Man, I don't have any,
I don't have any lime or salt or anything.
We'll figure that out. Uh, hey Dave,
this is a very brave move on your part.
Kudos.
Have you heard about the SJW nonsense?
I don't remember.
I don't even care about those guys. Does
it really just honestly, doesn't matter.
Uh, Viva La free speech. Good luck
Dave. Fuck you patriot and all right,
I'm reading these live, uh,
take a shot for me. Keep up
the amazing work. Good luck,
Dave.
Thanks for standing up to free speech.
Shout out to Carlos and to John
and to Michael. All right. Um,
okay. So here's what we're going to
do. I will pour a first shot, uh,
just to get this thing going here.
This is what the Internet
is really about people.
It's about people getting
drunk on Youtube, apparently.
I guess that's a big thing,
right?
Don't people get drunk and
cook or their estimates?
How can people get drunk and do a
little fundraising? Um, okay, let's see.
Um,
so we're going to do eat patrion I
don't know how long we're gonna do this.
I think we're gonna probably go
till about seven o'clock Pacific,
probably about two hours.
I'm just shooting the shit
with you guys. I'm happy to,
to, to answer any questions
and just talk whatever.
Um, and uh, shout out to
Nathan, shout out to Kendra,
shout out to Michael. Thank
you guys. Um, and yeah,
and then after that.
So let me just plot out a little bit
of sort of the way I see the future.
So look, we're, we're going to move
everybody to my website were read.
My website's actually pretty cool.
If you haven't been to Dave ruben.com
even if you don't want to donate,
I think we've done a nice job over there.
Uh,
you can see upcoming events that I have
and, and you know, the rest of it, um,
we are completely redoing
my website though,
when we're going to make it
much more of a destination.
So we're going to be hosting our own
videos. They're making sure that, uh,
that nothing can be taken down.
We're,
we're looking at all the pressure points
online of how you would take something
down.
How would you demonetize something?
How would you stop somebody
from posting video?
We're taking care of all of those things.
These are all also obviously within the
discussions that I'm having with Jordan
about, uh, the upcoming platform.
There's also a series of other things.
I don't want to make this seem like
this is only Jordan and I are working on
this.
Many of the players that you know,
whose names I need not mention at the
moment are working on all sorts of
different solutions to
this problem and who knows,
who knows what will be the right
solution to these problems.
But I'm also very enthused that I,
I've mentioned this before,
I'm getting a ton of,
um,
people from big tech companies,
from Google and Facebook and a whole bunch
of others that are reaching out to me
that are working at these companies
that are going on at the same, right?
What's going on here and we've
got to fight this monster. So I'm,
I'm very enthused about
that and we'll see if we can
grab some of these guys.
Um, all right guys.
I don't think that the mugs line at
the Mug tee shirt line I don't think is
loading right now.
Shout outs to William and to Jackson.
When are you coming to New England,
Dave? Um, I don't know that
we have any new England plans
at the moment. I will be,
I have a couple of Cali things coming up,
so I'm going to be in San Jose
and San Diego and Riverside,
California next week with Jordan Peterson.
And then uh,
I will be,
uh,
at the Irvine Improv in Orange
County on January 30th doing standup.
I do about an hour of standup. I bring
one of the ITW guys on stage. It's a,
it's an absolute blast. I
was in Ontario, California,
which I didn't realize was the place
and we had a lot of people in Ontario,
Canada, because both are ca that I think
showed up to the Improv over there,
but we had just a freaking, I
just crushed it for an hour. It's,
it's stand up like you've never seen
before. I'm barely telling jokes.
I go up there. I have a good
time. It's politically incorrect.
I get everybody involved. We do Q and.
A. I mess around with the crowd. It's,
it's fun. It's fun. Um,
so I hope you guys like
come out to that. Um, okay. Um,
let's see. Speaking of drinking,
will you have Michael Malice on the show
again, or when his new book comes out?
Is He an alcoholic or something?
I don't see the connection to drinking,
but I'd love to have Michael Analysis on.
Again, Michael is a, is a brilliant guy.
He's a really brilliant political thinker.
If you haven't seen my interview
with you should check it out.
I consider him the Willy Wonka of
politics. He's kind of Willy Wonka Ish.
Watched the interview, you'll see it.
It's also how he dresses. Uh, but he's,
he's a great political thinker. He's
more on sort of the AMCAP side of things.
Sort of like an extreme
libertarian view of freedom,
which I certainly love
exploring those ideas.
I think he's just got good energy and he's
good. Uh, Patrick, I'm signing your mug.
I guess the Mug thing just kicked in. All
right, Patrick, I'm signing a Mug for Ya.
Welcome on board. We've got about 50
mugs left. We're moving mugs people.
Patrick, you're getting the
first one. There you go, my
friend. Thank you very much.
Let's see. Uh, thank you, Mr Ruben.
I appreciate all your hard work and
you've truly opened my eyes to different
points and views. Try to get Dr.
Peterson to come down to Louisiana.
I don't think we did a show in Louisiana.
I'm pretty sure that after we do these
three in California that that'll be it
for this year. Jordan's writing a
new book and I'm writing a book.
Maybe Jordan will be opening for me on my
book tour. We shall see about that. Uh,
so there will be more tours obviously
in the United States. We're,
we're trying to think about some other,
uh,
touring ideas with some of the ITW crew.
As I mentioned,
I have this offer on the
table for all of April, uh,
all over the United States to take the
Rubin Report on the road and do pretty
big theaters like thousand thousand
to like 1500 seats per, uh,
per venue. So we're,
we're thinking about it.
I just got to figure out if I have
enough time to write. Um, so we're gonna,
we're gonna work on that, uh,
shout outs to Torbin and to Mike.
Welcome on board guys.
Thank you Dave.
Please try to get Dan
Crenshaw on your show.
He would be an interesting
guest in a rising star.
I completely agree and I'm happy to report
because we dropped live news on live
streams, uh, that I've
been in touch with Dan. Uh,
he is the new congressmen down in Texas.
Um, he is going to come on the show.
He's a fan of the show. He,
uh, he's happy to do it.
We're just trying to arrange it
during a trip that he has to, uh, la.
And by the way, since I will have a
freshman, like a freshman congressman,
like Dan Crunch on the show,
I will gladly have Alexandria Cortez or,
uh,
Omar Ilan or align Omar or whatever her
name is or a to lead or any of these
people that want to come in. I will
gladly talk to any of them. Uh, Dan is,
Dan is already a offered to come on,
so that'll be great. Uh, how about, uh,
Ruben report APP? We're in
discussions on many fronts. Uh,
I have a proposal sitting in my email
from a company that does pretty slick apps
and we're trying to, we're basically
just trying to streamline all of this.
I really think that the Internet is
changing right in front of us right now.
Like we've had,
I think we had like the first 10 years
of social media that were sort of the
glory years where everybody was meeting
everybody and people liked being on
Facebook and liked connecting with
people on Twitter and you could meet, um,
heroes of yours or athletes that you like
or authors and people were connecting
and it was all great.
Then in the last couple years,
the Internet started eating itself in
a way and the trolls took over and the
hate and all that stuff. Now
again, I say this meeting,
despite the fact that I would say 90%
despite I have an extremely dedicated
group of loser trolls that are always
following me and I just mute them.
Who Cares? Um, but, uh,
90% of what I see is positive.
So I think most of it's still positive.
But I think the, generally it's just
something to do with the human condition.
People focus on the negative more,
they focus on the positive.
So I think people think it's all horrible
even though it really isn't that bad.
But that's the other reason why being
on the tour has been so great because I
get to see actual people in real life
and they're often quite pleasant, uh,
as opposed to how they are online.
A shout out to Shamari and two mark.
Thank you guys. A super chat. I'm with
your brother. All right. Right on.
And keep up the great fight for free
speech. I have nothing better to do.
I mean really I was thinking
about it the other day,
like it was kind of big thing. Like some
of this can be a little a bit annoying.
Like I am sort of spread
thin in a certain way.
Like I'm trying to do my interview show,
I'm trying to do stand up,
I got a business to run and like I'm on
tour a whole bunch of other things and
now I'm sort of like half leading
a tech company. Uh, you know,
my weekends of just kind of
disappeared. Um, and, but it's like,
I don't know what else do I better
do? And it's, and it's more,
it's more fun to be spread thin
then when you're just like,
you have nothing to do. So life's
an adventure. I guess you guys are,
you guys are seeing my adventure. Um, all
right. Here's what we're gonna do. Uh,
if we got 100 bucks on a, on super chat,
the next hundred bucks on super chat,
I will take a, a shot of
Petrolia. There's a big shot too.
I should not have poured that,
that much of it in there. That was,
that was a mistake. Um, you're the
man. Ruben. Thank you very much.
I appreciate that. What the
hell are we doing here, people?
I am deleting Patrion all alive today.
Aaron,
let's go to the, uh, the video there.
So I'm gonna I just learned that you can
refresh your page on the computer there
if you press command are, that's very
fancy. So I'm refreshing the page.
I think I'm refreshing.
Did I refresh the page
command are maybe all right.
I'm going to refresh the old way,
the way I know how old school.
I'm refreshing the page. How are
we doing? Did we drop it all?
So we still have 1,777
people donating 9,000,
$911. I people please
cancel. Stop paying me there.
What are you doing? I don't know
what else to tell you guys. Please.
You've got to stop doing
it. You're, you're a,
I appreciate the sticktuitiveness
and the dedication, but I, you know,
join me over at the website,
Dave Rubin dotcom slash donate or don't,
but let's get you off paid round. Let's
save a couple bucks then for yourself.
Okay. What else is going on here? Uh, um,
okay. This iPad is going a
little slow right now. Um, okay.
Next hundred bucks on super
chat. I'm taking the shot. Um,
so what else is happening at
the moment? Um, you know what?
I'm going to tell you who we,
uh, who we interviewed today,
uh, because it was real,
it was really,
really,
really interesting day that I think is
sort of sums up so much of what's going
on here. And I think why you
guys, why you guys dig this thing.
So we started the day
with Dr. Everett Piper,
who is the president of
Oklahoma Wesleyan University,
which is a small college about
1500 students. He is a staunch,
staunch defender of intellectual freedom
and he's written several books on it
and why, why were, were coddling these
young people and why it's terrible. Uh,
he comes from a, a, it's
a Christian university,
comes from a Christian perspective.
And we talked a lot about
ethics and we talked about, uh,
living with honor and where to rights
come from and a lot of my wheelhouse
things.
What with a little bit of a religious
perspective that we've done a little bit
before. W fascinating guy. Like I just,
one of the things that I like most is when
I get a guest who really you can tell,
really knows their ideas in and out,
uh,
and can tackle them in all
sorts of different ways. Uh,
I just loved that and he was
truly a master of his idea.
So we're posting in that one tomorrow.
We're doing it in one piece. Uh, then, uh,
we took about a half hour break,
had lunch, had a salad and a,
then I interviewed Heather McDonald
from the Manhattan Institute.
And I'm sure most of you know
Heather McDonald. Uh, she's,
she's a really fascinating public
figure who's taken some pretty,
um, politically incorrect positions
on welfare, on black lives matter,
on the me too movement.
Uh,
she writes extensively about sort of
third wave feminism and how it's gone
haywire and the assault on men,
which is obviously becoming more
and more relevant to you guys.
See this idiotic Gillette Promo
that they put up yesterday. Um,
it's just embarrassing like this,
this need for these companies
to embrace social justice,
which is such a Brott. It's intellectual
rot and these companies just go for it.
Hook, line and sinker. Uh, it's
just pathetic and awful. Um,
let's see. So, uh, so I had Heather
on, it was great discussion.
Unfortunately had to cut, cut it kind
of quick cause she was in a rush. Uh,
so we only did about 50 minutes or so.
And then my third one was
really interesting conversation
with the guide by the
name of Tall Keenan and he is an American
Israeli who's written sort of a book
about sort of what he thinks the history
of the Jews or the future of the Jews
is going to be. Which I thought was sort
of interesting because we've done a lot,
um,
I've done more on,
especially on theology and religion
related to people when it's come to
Christianity who haven't
done that much on Judaism,
although I've had rabbi Wolpe
on a couple of times. Um,
so it was really just an
really interesting day.
And what was particularly
interesting about it was, um,
that my day started talking to a guy who,
who talks about things from
a Christian perspective. Um,
Heather considers herself
a secular conservative,
which we talked about because
people don't think that that exists.
People seem to think that to be a true
conservative, you have to be religious.
Well, she makes a great point
that you do not in fact,
and you'll hear more about that in the
interview. And then it ended up talking,
um, with somebody talking about the
future of Judaism. So I thought, wow,
this is what I mean. You want
to talk about diversity? Uh,
now they all happen to be white, although
tall was, was more brown I suppose. Um,
but uh,
this was diversity of thought and that
is the diversity of matter that matters.
Did you know that Jake John
and Joe three is in a row?
Thank you guys. Uh, okay. Super
Cha. All right, here we go.
I'm a man of my word
getting too old for this.
42 years old to 42 year olds
do shot. Is that a thing? Um,
well a 42 year olds about,
oh, and they brought,
I've got an all star team here.
Let me,
let me put this in front of the
computer for a second. I've got a,
let's put that in front of the computer.
I've got Lyme, I've got salt. Oh God.
That's the screenshot right there.
Uh, all right, I'm going to do it.
All right. Oh, but another one, take
the shot. All right, here we go.
Uh, it's been a long time
coming. So little salt.
Here we go. Got Salt, got
Tequila. They had a little salt.
There's a little tequila.
I do like lime. I've always
liked lime. I like sprite.
You're not supposed to drink it.
I don't really drink it that often.
A sprite zero every now
and again, although that'll
kill you too. But I do like,
I like lemon lime. I like
citrus. All right, there you go.
So I hope you're happy person who did
that. Thank you very much. Oh man,
I really haven't eaten today. I had a
salad and I had two glasses, a bone bra.
This could be very messy.
People. What am I doing?
I'm deleting Patrion and taking
shots of patron and we're,
we're fundraising to keep the show fully
independent. Look, I'm not going to,
I don't intend on doing fundraisers
a lot throughout the year. We,
we've done a nice job. We've transitioned
a whole good portion of people.
The business is going to continue,
I promise you that we're trying to just
get to the same levels that we were at
before. Uh, so, so I don't know.
My guys were saying we should be trying
to get to a specific number right now or
we should try to raise a certain amount
over the course of this two hours or
something like that. Um, I dunno, we're,
we're just kind of playing it by ear and
then I will click on patrion and delete
it. Let me see. Did anyone drop? Aaron
jump back over there. Has anyone dropped?
I'm trying to get these people to
drop. We'll anyone drop. Did we? Yes.
We lost six people.
That's what I'm talking about.
We lost six people on Patrion and we
dropped out of the, I didn't see it,
the amount of money on that,
but I am thrilled to report people.
We are slowly dropping patrons.
I can do this.
I can do a 24 hour stream and just wait
for these because some of these people
could be dead for all I know. I don't
know what's going on here. All right,
let's see. Time to take the shot. Bring
out Joe Rogan. This is the second person.
Another shot. No, I think what we're
going to have to do, it will be insane.
If I do this for every hundred dollars,
then I do a shout.
I will be dead before I'm able to
press delete on this thing. So, uh,
I don't know. The next shot has to be
500 bucks. That sounds crazy. But like,
I don't know. It's the Internet. People
do crazy things. Um, but I, I will,
I'll do a couple more. We'll figure
it out. All right. Good luck brother.
Patrion is a joke anyway. Are you going
to ever get norm Mcdonald on? Yeah.
You know,
I met norm at a,
at Aura TV when I was over there with
Larry King and chatted with him in the
green room. He said he'd do it. We
haven't just been able to connect,
but I would love to have him on.
Sometimes people say,
I sound like Norm Macdonald. Um, I
love norm McDonald from weekend update.
That
was basically the last time I
watched Saturday night live.
Does anyone watch that crap anymore?
I would love to know that in the comments.
Like, does anyone watch television
anymore at all? Um, I don't,
I watch on Sundays,
TV land does like 8:00 AM to
4:00 PM Golden Girls Marathon.
And I kind of have that on the background
when I'm doing other stuff in the
house or just like laying there with
my dog or whatever. But I don't,
I don't watch any television.
I haven't watched,
we'll certainly s cable news or CNN
or anything like that. And forever.
I watch ancient aliens every now and
again. And you like the ancient aliens.
I like them, you know, ancient
alien theorists theorize
that canceling Patrion. Uh,
and going over to Dave rubin.com/donate
is one of the best things that you can
do. A, okay, good luck brother
Bill. I just did that one. Um,
Dave, good luck with all the
avenues you're pursuing in 2019.
What are your predictions for
Democratic candidates in 2020?
Will they fracture similar
to the Republicans in 2016
or the establishment will
be establishment back one candidate?
I'm,
I'm a little hesitant
to say this because a,
I'm so frustrated with what's happening
on the left and the Democrats and the
progressives that I don't want to tip
them off to what I think is going to
happen. Um, but this is
just between me and you. Um,
I think it's going to be
a freaking bloodbath. Uh,
I think that between Elizabeth
Warren, let's say Bernie, uh,
now they've got Tulsi Gabard.
Uh,
there'll be a couple others on the
progressive side. They'll throw, you know,
maybe a Cory booker. They'll throw in
someone who's a little more mainstream.
I don't know exactly who that is
because there aren't really mainstream,
there aren't really blue dog,
more centrist Democrats anymore.
Say a guy like Jim Webb who was in one
debate last time and he looked like he
was on the wrong stage. Those people
don't really exist. So what we're, we're,
I think you're going to happen is,
uh,
if further splintering of the
progressive thing and the,
the Kamala Harris people let's say,
are going to call the Bernie supporters
racist because he's white and they're
going to call them this because
they're this. And you know,
and also you're seeing these people try
to pretend that they're human. I mean,
watching you guys saw that video where
Elizabeth Warren drank the beer with her
husband and he just happened
to be standing there and
they try to pretend that
they're normal,
average people or Kamala Harris did the
video with the music that she likes and
they're just robots.
It's like Trump standing in the White
House surrounded by 10,000 burgers is more
of a human than what these people are.
So in a weird way,
as much as I would love,
and I want to be clear about this as much
as I would love for a decent Democrat
to return a good liberal, uh, JFK liberal,
a Daniel Patrick Moynihan and Ed Kotch
and old school liberal to return from the
ashes of this lunacy, it's going
to get worse before it gets better.
And that that person, I don't know where
the hell that that person is. Uh, I,
it doesn't seem to me that anyone
can tell me who that person is. Um,
even though you know that person,
who would that be?
Maybe that's a Joe Biden of 20 years ago,
who was more of a mainstream democrat.
But if the future of, of the Democrats
is Joe Biden who is what, 70, 74,
something like that, then they're in
a lot of trouble anyway. And, and I,
that is not to say anything
about the Republicans. I'm,
I'm happy to answer questions
about the Republican's. Yep.
You got them. Um, but
yes, let's see. Okay.
Um, let's see, uh, shout
outs to Martha and to Nathan.
Let's see. A super superchat subbed
for $50 on your site 30 minutes ago,
long until you sign my mug.
Uh,
I'm not sure what you're
saying exactly there.
My guys are telling me the mug thing,
but my iPads loading a little slow.
So here we're going to do for ya
imaginary person, I believe you.
So I'm signing a Mug for you. I'm going
to put this one aside and let guys,
let's track that super chat and
figure out what's going on here. Uh,
Mahalo Day for all things free speech
is lucky to have you as a close friend.
Keep up all of the awesome
Mahalo, my friend, uh,
ch Viva free speech indeed. Um, hey Dave,
thanks for all you do.
You should have met Fred on to discuss
his work on pornography and its effect on
culture.
You know, a few people have mentioned him
before. I actually have his book here.
Uh, he talks a lot about
people's addiction to
pornography and a bunch of other
things. I actually think it's
a pretty interesting topic.
It just hasn't happened yet. Uh,
you know, I will do it. We will
make it happen. Uh, hang
tight. A reminder guys.
Uh,
I'm at Irvine Improv with an IDW
guests on January 30th they sold out.
So the,
one of the funny things that my stand up
shows that we didn't realize is that we
do usually about 50 seats out of,
usually clubs have about 300 seats are
saying we do about 50 seats for a meet
and greet and you pay a little bit extra,
you get seated in the front.
And then I meet people and shake hands
and take pictures after and all that.
Those are all selling our crazily quickly.
So they sold out immediately.
I asked the guys today to release 10 more,
so I'm not sure if
they're still available,
but you can check at [inaudible] dot com
slash events you can click over there
and see if there's any more meet
and greets available. Uh, but we'll,
we'll make it happen. But you know
what, here's what we'll do. Here's what,
this is going to complicate
things for my guys a little bit,
but anyone that donates,
if you donate 25 bucks or more a
month during this live stream, uh,
we'll have your email address and you,
we will email you if you want to come
to any of those shows and you can't get
tickets to the,
to the upgrade or you don't even want,
you don't even have to upgrade.
If you ended up at the Irvine show,
we'll gladly upgrade you
to the meet and greet.
I'll make sure it happens. We will
do that. So, okay, let's move on. Uh,
thanks for the good fight,
Dave. Much respect. I appreciate
it. Look at you. Nice
people will be in good on super chat
every now and again. I glanced, you know,
we post the live stream.
This tells you a little bit about
the ecosystem of Youtube, but we, uh,
we post the live stream on youtube and
our glance before we get on there about
what's going on in the comments section
and I don't know what you people are
doing, what are you people do?
You're all fighting with each other,
saying horrible things to each other.
Often the ones that amazed me the
most though, I really mean this,
and I just glanced for literally like
literally 30 seconds and it's like there's
all these people that seemingly don't
like me in this comment section and I
don't care if you don't like me.
I actually don't.
But what I would say to you is
what are you doing your life?
Get off this channel.
What are you doing if you don't like me,
go find something to do.
I mean,
there's plenty of other things
you could be doing right now.
You could take a run, uh, you could play
some video games. You could watch porn.
I mean, there's many other you could
write, I don't know. What do you do?
You could make coffee,
you could stare at a fish tank.
There's a zillion things you could do
better than just endlessly sit there.
They were with [inaudible]. What are
you doing? Tell me what you're doing.
If you're watching this right now,
which I'm sure you are,
what are you doing with your life?
What can we do for you?
I would recommend reading 12 rules for
life by Jordan Peterson that might help
clean up your room people. Okay.
Uh, oh by the way. All right,
so we should clarify something because
there seems to be a little confusion here.
Uh,
first off,
I thank you guys that are all jumping in
on super chat and I know that's a cool
way of getting your voice heard.
And I'm reading them all right here.
We're not censoring any of this nonsense.
Um,
but the only way we're giving away stuff,
again, the shirts that are right here,
which are in limited supply,
I would love to get rid of them and I need
some closet space. You know my studio,
this is my garage,
so I don't have a garage anymore.
We built a state of the art studio here.
Uh, and you know what I'll do, we'll do,
I do this for,
for patrons,
but I often do videos where I just kind
of wandered around and I show you the
whole thing and it's pretty awesome.
So if you haven't seen what,
what sort of the behind
the scenes of this is,
is you guys on Patrion on that and that
the people that have allowed us to fan
fund you guys, you truly, I
mean it's not a, it's not a uh,
it's not hyperbole or a sarcastic remark
to say that you made my dreams come
true. I built, I bought
this house cause you guys,
I built this studio cause you guys,
we built a state of the art studio when
Tucker Carlson walked in here a couple
of weeks ago.
Um,
he now think about this talking about
and as the number one show on cable news,
I have no idea how many millions
of dollars a year he's making,
but it's millions and millions of dollars
a year. He walks into my garage and he,
he literally, I don't know if he's
going to want me to quote him exactly,
but it was something to the effect of
Holy fucking Shit, this is your garage.
Like he was,
he was actually jealous of this cool
thing that we've been able to build here
and my freedom and all that. And that's
not a knock on Fox by him in any way.
He loves what he's doing.
I was on his show later that night and
they treat them great and he's, you know,
he's become a huge ally in this space of
related to free speech and the rest of
it.
And you get the guy gets unending hate.
I mean for the amount of hate that I get.
It's like you attach Fox to your name
and now mainstream is just obsessed with
you because they just want the clicks
and views that you're getting. Right.
And that's why the more hate that
I get, the more I'm like, oh,
I guess I am doing something right.
Because people say Nice things to me.
I'm like, all right, well I guess I'm all
right. I am doing what I think is right.
But then all these people
that hate me, I'm like, boy,
you're really spending a lot of time
thinking about me. Okay. Um, but anyway,
because of fan funding,
we've been able to do this,
but I don't have a garage anymore.
So we don't have a lot of
storage space in this house.
And if I can move some of those
boxes of mugs and tee shirts,
that would actually be wonderful.
Shout outs to Chris and Christine.
Are they a couple? I do not
know. We'll find out. Um,
okay, let's see. Uh,
gave $50 on your site and no place for
us to enter details on there, right?
A heart on my mug. When you sign it, you
glorious gay bastard. Love you. Okay.
So have you gave money on the site? So
we'll find out who that last person was.
They gave 50.
Um,
we then have your email address and
we will email you with all of the
information. So fear not, we'll get you.
So I'm going to sign the
Mug for you right now.
I feel good about that d right there.
That's a good d.
And you want a heart on that thing? You're
gay bastard or right? No, Homo Dude,
you got a heart. You got a heart too.
All right, there you go. Let's see.
Okay. Uh, hey Dave,
are you going to do anything on comic
skate and the blacklisting slash doxing of
people in the comics industry? So
this thing keeps popping up. I,
to be totally honest with you,
my bandwidth try, you know,
try to imagine what my bandwidth is
like at the moment to be able to take in
like enough stories that are related to
all of the things that are going on with
this and try to do all the things
I'm trying to do every now and again.
Something that I know should not
get by me does get by me. Um,
so I know I need to pay more attention
to this and also like I come from the
world of comic books. I love, you
know, in our green room here and I'll,
I'll post some videos of this also
soon and I've done it before for,
for the behind the
scenes Patriot on thing.
That's what I was trying to
get you earlier. Um, I love
comics. I love comics. I,
I've some of my old comic collection
posted in the green room right over there.
Um,
so I know I need to know more about this.
I know there's been some like
SJW madness related to comics.
I know it's leaking into the video
game world. And in into everywhere. Oh,
I had a question for you. So this
past weekend on a, on Sunday,
I took a couple of meetings in the
morning. I try not to work on the weekend,
but it never works.
I always had to doing it,
but I had a couple hours in the afternoon
and it was pouring rain here in La and
it never rains and I had a couple of
hours in the afternoon to like do nothing.
And I was actually like, Holy Shit, I
could actually do nothing right now.
Watched a couple episodes
of the golden girls.
Then I go into the green room here.
So we,
one of the bedrooms in my house is the
green room and a for those of you that
are on Patrion, you've seen,
we have a great green room,
like it's totally comfortable
for all the guests.
We got an espresso machine in there and
we got a a fully stocked fridge with
whatever they want and there
we've got snacks in there.
I've also got all my video
game systems in there.
So I've got my old school a bit
and ies, Nintendo. I got contrary.
I got Super Mario, I got the original
baseball, I got bases loaded, I got, uh,
what else do I got? I got, I got a
pro wrestling, a lot of the classics.
I've got a sega genesis in there,
um,
with altered beast and goals and
ghosts and NBA live and all that stuff.
I've got a playstation four. The
calamari already got me. I've got a,
a Nintendo switch that a fan got me
and I think that's it on the video game
department. Anyway, so I was like, I'm
going to play some video games. Uh,
so first I played my brother in law in no,
first I played my nephew in,
uh, NBA Two k 19. Um, and
I was thinking, you know,
maybe one of the rewards for
people that are high tier donors.
Maybe I would start giving out my,
my handle on playstation four and every
now and again I'd play people in Nba
live or NBA Two k, whatever it is, or
in some other co op gains. I really,
I like co op games where
we're working together.
I don't need to fight you and blow your
brains out and spit your guts all over
the place or punch a hooker if we
can work together to fix the world.
That that's more my thing. Um, so if you
can think of, so my question is this.
So first off, my, my, uh, that
that patrolling works, um, my,
uh, nephew, my nine year old,
every first I have to kicked my ass
in Nba two k was pathetic. It was,
but he used the warriors.
Now of course you're using the warriors.
You got Thompson, you got, you got, uh,
you got curry. Okay. I get it. You know,
you got, uh, uh, Jesus Christ. Oh my God,
Duran, uh, you know, they're,
they're unstoppable. Basically.
I was using the 91 trailblazers,
which is probably my,
it's my second favorite basketball team
of all time except for the 95 rockets.
And he just mocked me.
I like to be beaten by 30 points
by a nine year old is pathetic. Uh,
then I played my brother
in law. He crushed me. He,
although he was the 93 bolts,
which you know, you're using Jordan in
his prime and then a, and then I was like,
all right, I'm going to play by myself.
Like what can I play and everything.
I don't want to run all over the place
and have to spend all this mental energy
on a world that I don't live in.
I spend a lot of mental energy on this
world here that I seem to be living in,
so I couldn't.
I ended up playing PAC man.
I literally ended up playing PAC man on
playstation four because I couldn't find
something sort of mindless and simple.
So if you've got a simple mindless game,
that would be great. I also like,
I like just bullet hell shooters,
so if you've got a couple of good ones,
I was playing our type and Rezo
gun and a couple of others.
I don't really have time for any of this,
frankly,
but if you've got some good ideas, let
me know. All right guys. Uh, here we go.
My team wants me to do
a little reset here.
I'm giving shout outs for
anyone that donates at all.
If you donate five bucks in above,
it doesn't matter.
I've given live shoutouts
Dave rubin.com/donate.
If you donate $25 or above monthly,
you're going to get a limited edition.
Ruben reports, select members, sure
that we'll never be printed again.
I think we've about a hundred of
them left, probably less than that.
Maybe about 80 of them left. Uh, and you'd
be cleaning out closets space for me,
which would really be great cause I don't
have a garage anymore so we don't have
a lot of rumor out here.
Uh, that will be great.
We'll give you a tee shirt and
for 50 bucks a month or more,
you're going to get the t shirt and
you're going to get a mug and I'm going to
sign it for you and we're going
to send it out to you this week.
So do let me know what's going
on over there. Canada loves you,
Dave. Thank you. I love Canada.
I get a ton of email from Canada.
I did about 10 Canadian stops
with JP and Canada and, uh,
I think Canada there, there's
an interesting resurgence
of liberty in Canada,
which is really interesting that you
actually, we're going to have libertarian,
a prime minister, candidate,
prime ministerial candidate. Uh,
Maxine Bernay is going to be on the show.
We were going to do it via Skype,
but I just got an email this morning.
He's coming here,
come in directly to the
studio. Maxine Bernay, uh,
will be here within the next week or
so. So we'll do that one. You know what?
Let's jump over to the, uh, to
the computer monitor as it were.
I'm going to hit refresh.
Let's see.
Please tell me that you people have
canceled this thing. You killing me?
You're killing me. Stop giving
me money here. All right.
We dropped 14 people.
We're down to 1,757 people
still around $10,000.
I don't know.
No. What I can do. What are you
doing? Cancel this. Whoa. Stop please.
People, you don't have to donate anymore.
Even on my website if you don't want,
but, but please, let's end this thing.
Why are we giving these people money?
All right, let's see. Uh, okay.
Shout out to James.
Thank you very much. Uh,
I'm a college student who goes to a
campus that is extremely liberal and I'm
somewhat of a libertarian.
Any advice for me not to get killed,
but still at the bank?
Free speech. Well, that's
the state of affairs.
If you believe in liberty and freedom
and you don't want to bother anybody and
you don't want to take their shit, but
you don't want them to take your shit, uh,
you don't, you might be getting killed.
Um, my advice would be this, which is,
this is the exact same advice that I
give every college kid when I go to every
college,
a speaking gig that I do,
which is be brave. Now. That's it.
You must be brave now. You will
not get out of college. Really,
really hear this. I think this is the
most true thing that I can possibly say.
If you're in college right now and
you're afraid to say what you think,
do you think that it magically
is gonna get better? Um,
if you think things are screwed up and
maybe the generation before you is the
one that screwed him up,
do you think that it will magically
get better by your silence?
Do you think that the people who are
allowed right now will eventually give you
an inch because of your
acquiescence? Uh, no.
They will keep taking
and taking and taking.
And that's why what happened to me with
this patriotic thing was, all right,
we could let them,
they booted some people and we,
we maybe dropped the
ball on some are ignored,
some or that person were shady or
I didn't want to make that one.
The exact example of why I would
stand up and defend the line. Um,
but then the line moves,
the line moves and if you're afraid
to see what you think, now you're 18,
you're 19 years old.
Uh,
and if you think that it will
magically get better, it will not,
it will get worse.
We live in the most privileged in
the best sense of it. We're pretty,
if you live in the United State,
you are privileged.
You are the freest person in the
freest society that there possibly is.
It doesn't mean you have everything.
It doesn't mean you came from everything.
He doesn't mean you'll attain everything,
but you live in a place that will give
you the opportunity to do all of the
things that you want in your life,
but it's on you to do them.
It's on you to do them.
So if you're 18 or 19 years old
and you're in college right now,
and you're afraid to say what you think,
if you don't do it now,
it'll never get easier.
Do you think when you get out of college
in three years and now you've got a
rent, you gotta Pay Rent, right? Well,
you're going to suddenly be like,
I'm going to tell the world would I think,
and then three years later you're
married and you've got a mortgage.
I'm going to tell the world what I think.
You've got car payments and dog.
Now you've got kids. It's three
months later now or three years later.
Now you've got all sorts
of other payments, school
payments and blah, blah, blah.
I building for, I'm going to tell the
world what I think. You won't. You won't,
it's on you.
Now.
There's no better moment than right this
moment to start saying what you think.
And part of the reason
that this SJW lunacy,
um, is, is spreading is because they're
allowed and they call everyone racist.
So they've silenced good people.
There is an, I assure you guys, look,
I'm doing the best I can.
I'm just doing what I think is right.
I say that all the time. I am just one
person. And guess what? I'm still here.
And Douglas Murray,
Douglas Murray,
who I think is one of the greatest
modern thinkers that we have,
who I've had in the studio. If you
haven't seen our interviews, watch it.
And Douglas Murray talks about
extremely controversial talk topics.
He talks about radical Islam.
He talks about immigration,
a whole bunch of things.
Um, and he's gay and
conservative in, in the UK.
Um, I asked him, well,
what makes you so brave?
Why are you willing to talk about
these things? What you meeting?
You have this person in front of me.
Why are you willing to
talk about these things?
And he said in a wonderful British
accent that I can't quite do.
But he said, you know, Dave,
when you get in the pool,
you might find out that
the water is not that cold.
I wish I could done that with a little
more of a Cockney Downton Abbey accident.
But the point is that if you guys jump in,
you might find out that all of the
things that you fear are not as terrible.
The monster isn't as terrible.
And I'm just,
I'm not saying the monster doesn't
exist because it does exist,
but we got to start fighting
back together. And if you
think at 18, if you stop,
if you're thinking about these things
now, you know what, let's try it this way.
Imagine if my advice was, you
know, what, suck it up. Suck
it up. Get Out of college.
Does that seem like the right advice?
And I don't think so. We'll see.
Let's see.
Um,
always enjoy your perspective on
what's going on in this crazy world.
Come to Oklahoma City. We're
figuring out the standup tour. Uh,
so hang tight on Oklahoma City.
Looking forward to seeing
you in San Jose next weekend.
Thanks for the meet and greet comps.
I guess I gave you meet, greet comps.
My pleasure.
You said before that you're a Sinatra Fan.
What's your favorite song or album
by Frank? I love the question.
I love not getting always
political questions.
If you guys want to ask me anything else,
there's not political,
that'd be great too. Oh, quick shout
outs to marry to Kelly to fill up.
Thank you guys. Um, Dave rubin.com/donate.
Let me give you a shirt and a mug.
People, um, I'm moving product
and we're officially deleting.
Patrion we'll delete in a, it looks
like it's going to be about an hour.
We're going to delete this thing or unless
I just magically do it at a nowhere.
I could just get sick of this
and just be like, you know,
I'm hungry and I got to go.
But we are deleting patrion live.
I love the fact that like there
are these like silicon valley,
like people watching like, oh my
God, it's he it there. All right.
When's he going to do it? Why does
this mean? It's like, it's so boring.
The group think thing. It's just so
boring. My favorite Sinatra Song by far,
by far my way by far,
every word of that song is something that
I try to live up to. It's just, I'm not,
I'm not going to sing
it for you right now,
but open up another youtube tab and
listened to my way. And that is,
that is how I try to live my life,
that I don't always succeed at it. Um,
but it's just great. Let's do the line
about regrets. Regrets. I've had a few,
I mean, just, just listen. It's just,
it's just perfection. But you know,
believe it or not,
I actually think pound for pound.
If I could only listen
to Frank Sinatra or Dean Martin,
if I had to choose between one of the
two, I might go dean Martin. I really,
really love Dean Martin, especially
when, uh, when David's cooking Italian,
I can listen to Dean Martin all the time.
Dean Martin's a little lighter.
There's like a little more play in
d more in than there isn't Sinatra.
And I, I really do love that. Uh, oh,
okay. Sorry. Mary Kelly and Philip.
I didn't, uh, I didn't realize
you guys were mugs. Sorry.
I'm going to sign your mugs. What I do
with the pen. All right, here we go. Mary,
you're getting a Mug by the way guys,
do not,
I've been warned about this.
If you put this mug
with the signature in the, uh, in
the dishwasher, it will rub off.
So either hand wash it or I
was told if you bake them,
but I don't want to be held legally
responsible for this. If you bake the Mug,
that somehow
the ink like gets into the Mug and
you'll be okay. So that is Mary,
that is Kelly and fill up and you
guys are all getting t shirts as well.
Thank you guys. All
right, there we go. Um,
all right. You know what I
said? I said 500 for a shot.
We'll do 200 for a shot on a on super
chat. Go for it. Shout out to you all.
Thank you very much.
Uh, let's see. Um, do,
do, do, do, uh, if he ever
gets out of the embassy,
Julian Assange would be a great guest.
Yeah.
Yeah. I'd be happy to talk to them. I
wonder if we could do that via Skype.
He's done a couple interviews.
I think
I would obviously be more than
happy to do that. Um, hey Dave,
I'm doing $50 a month. Have you had a
chance to look at Christina Bichons work?
She's a professor at Oxford and wrote
a book about political civility. I,
the name actually does not ring a bell.
I will tell you this. I went to, uh,
well first of all guys, can we add, add
her name to the list
beyond bi. J. O. N. M.
I went to Oxford twice in the last
year. Um, I spoke at Oxford Union,
which the video is on youtube
on their youtube channel.
It was one of the greatest
honors that I've, well,
it might be the greatest
professional honor that I've had.
It was just an incredible place to
be. I mean, if you go to Oxford,
if you haven't been there, it looks like
it's right out of Harry Potter. It's,
it's just incredible.
And they, they, you know,
they have these small schools everywhere
and there's such a respect for learning
and knowledge and the libraries are
incredible and there's just young people
everywhere who are interested
in knowledge. It's actually
amazing. Um, I had, uh,
what I think was one of
my best public talks.
He was extremely intimate
and really lovely.
I got asked some really
challenging questions at the end,
some really interesting stuff. And
it was, it was a pleasure to do that.
And then I went back again with Jordan a
couple months ago and it's just a great
place. And you know, I've mentioned
this before, but going around the world,
you know, in the last couple months
I was in awe. I was in Norway.
I'll just mention the countries, not
all the cities, but I was in Ireland,
I was in Norway, I was in Sweden,
I was in Denmark. I was in,
did I say Ireland already? I was in the
UK. Uh, obviously we're in the states.
We were in Canada,
we're going to be doing France and Germany
and we're trying to get to the Middle
East and a whole bunch of other places
in the next couple of months.
But seeing that these ideas permeate
around the world and that people, I mean,
trying to think how cool it
is that somebody, right now,
there's somebody in Brazil watching this,
thinking a similar thought as someone in
Iceland who's thinking of some similar
thoughts as someone who's in Jordan,
as someone in Russia. I mean that,
that's actually incredible and that's
a really beautiful thing and that's why
the Internet has to be
protected. And that's why we
have to protect free thought.
And it's why we have to
protect our ability to
communicate each other with each
other. So let's keep doing that. Kyle,
you're getting a mug. All right, let's go.
Um, keep fighting the good fight,
Dave. All right. That's the plan.
That is the plan. Kyle, you are getting
a mug. Okay. Thank you very much. Uh,
all right, quick reset. Since
we're about an hour and, or,
you know, let's go to the,
uh, let's go to the computer.
Over here. We are on the computer.
Now please tell me that we
lost at least a hundred people.
I don't know what to do here to
get rid of you people. Uh, 1757.
We are down to
1756.
That's right people.
And the 20 minutes since I did that,
we lost one person and I thank you.
Whoever that is. You know what? I
want to send that person a month.
We'll send that person a mug.
If we can find out who that person is.
I want to send them a mug and a tee
shirt if you just canceled on Patrion.
Thank you.
I don't know what I can do for you guys.
So I have to send you guys money.
Maybe I should start a Kickstarter to
raise money to give money to you people to
cancel the patrion thing. Uh,
Lordy, Lordy, a Mug for Carrie.
You're getting a Mug, sister. Thank you
for support. Uh, it's much appreciated.
All right people,
I'm ready to do another shot at patrol.
I don't know what's happened here.
Let's, uh, let's make it happen.
200 on super chat or a,
or you know what,
a hundred monthly on Dave Rubin. Dot.
Conversation donate. We'll make it happen.
I don't know, I'm just having fun
here. Like let's just keep rolling. Um,
you're a legend Dave. Keep up the good
work. Can't wait to see you in Australia.
I really can't wait to go to Australia.
I get a ton of email from Australia.
Australia I think is our fourth
most listened to country.
Usually it's the United
States, Canada, UK and then,
and then I think Australia and Germany
or sometimes Australia and Sweden.
Flip on that on the next most followed.
Now Sweden's a particularly interesting
case because there's only about 10
people that live there.
And I think,
I think I met everybody at
the two shows with Jordan,
the second show that I did
with Jordan in Stockholm,
which was an amazing theater and
they were two of my favorite shows.
I really loved all the Nordic
countries actually. Um,
but the day before we did the
second show with Jordan, um,
the Swedish foreign minister whose
name is escaping me at the moment,
might be Kiersten something.
Kristin, Kristin something. Uh,
she said that she wishes the Jordan
Peterson would crawl back under the rock.
He came from off the foreign minister
of a Western country was upset that a
clinical psychologist who
talks about free speech and,
and personal responsibility
and the rights of the and and
defending the,
the values of Western society.
She wants him to crawl back
under the rock he's came from.
I mean that's how stupid
everything has gotten.
A though I do have to thank her because
I got a lot of good laughs at her
expense. A super chat. Thank you for
doing what you do Dave. You got it.
Hey, I signed up for 50 hours a month. I
was wondering what your favorite car was.
Um, man, these Teslas right now,
have you guys been in these Teslas?
They are UN freaking believable.
Like driving a Tesla and
then driving any other car,
the newest anything and you will be
like, wow, what a jump in technology.
I mean they are smooth and clean.
There's no buttons.
It's all on that huge screen there.
There are self driving, you know,
the model x has the Delorean style wings.
Um,
they're just absolutely like
sick and cool. There's a
ton of them here in La. Uh,
and on top of the fact that they're fully
electric obviously and everything else
and a lot of must shot went into space
just because he could, I mean that,
that's something I'm the minister of
foreign affairs in Sweden is Margo
Walstrom. That's right. Margo
Walstrom. She is not Kiersten anything.
I made that up. Uh, let's see. Um,
when you interview Maxine,
Bernie asked him about the dairy industry.
He says he wants to follow
in Australia path. However,
Australian farmers killed themselves
in shop in shocking numbers when they
eliminated quotas.
I will be totally honest with you.
I don't know anything about that.
Let me do a little research.
I'll try to make it happen. Okay. Um,
nonpolitical question, ginger or
Maryanne, oh, sorry, I forgot.
Geo Gilligan or skipper,
what's wrong with you people?
You know, like really why,
what kind of question is
that? Skipper, obviously, but
what, what's wrong with you?
You know, it's an odd question.
Why are you asking that?
Uh, Shah Mug for Christian.
All right, here you go, Christian.
Thank you guys. You know,
one of the things that you're
also doing in the meantime,
so we are building out this platform.
As I said,
we're trying to figure out ways
to secure the monetization.
We're trying to figure out ways to
secure the video hosting to secure, uh,
not only that, but the, the web hosting,
there's ways to decentralize
that even we're,
we're trying to figure out all of the
pressure points and how do we deal with
them systematically and make sure that
we're taken care of on all fronts.
We're trying to figure out what it,
what does a terms of service in 2019,
what does a true terms of service
look like? Should it be as simple as,
it's just you have to follow the laws of
the United States where we have no hate
speech laws, but you can't, you know,
make a terrorist threat or yell fire in
a crowded theater or a criminal threat
or direct violence, things like
that. Could it be that, well,
there's an argument that that could be it.
And I think that's a legit argument.
But then what happens the
day we opened this platform,
all of the racists and
the white supremacists and
all of these awful people,
let's say they get on on the site.
Now,
I'm not against them
expressing their free speech.
I think you guys obviously know that
even if I find their ideas, I pour in.
The problem is that,
imagine
now we start this site and out
of the first 2000 accounts,
1500 of them are these people because
they've been banned off the other sites.
Well now what is the entire media?
And we know the media is just mostly
a bunch of nonsense anyway, the,
the entire media now
jumps on board and is, Oh,
you see Reuben and Peterson or running
the outright racist website. And then,
you know, we uh, we'll hopefully have
investors and board members and all that.
And then all the pressure is
applied on them. So we have to,
we have to calculating Lee and clearly
think about what does it terms of service
look like?
How do you launch a launch,
a new platform as a platform and have to
be launched that on day one everyone's
on it or should it be,
I'm coming around to this idea that it
would be a tiered invitation system.
So let's say we launched
with say 50 people, right?
So let's say it's like sort of IDW people
in adjacent people and then then that
sort of the Beta test version
of it, right? As the creator.
But anyone can sign on to follow a
creator, but that's the creator tier.
And then maybe over three months
as we're testing all things out,
each creator gets five invites to five
other creators and then you exponentially
grow from there. I think something
like that could be interesting.
I also think people are sick of the fact
that anyone can get on anything and do
whatever they want and the
whole thing's a free for all.
I think actually people
do like some rules,
but they liked him to be
actually enforced consistently.
Not In this crazy way that they're
enforced right now. Shout out to Cody.
Thank you very much Cody. Uh, if I
remember your, if I remember correctly,
you were a blazers fan.
I think the Blazers get rid of either
Lillard or McCollum if they don't make a
deep playoff push.
So I'm an early nineties,
a blazers fan because Clyde
Drexler was my favorite hero. Uh,
if you weren't an NBA fan in
the early nineties, uh, Clyde,
the glide was basically the number two
shooting guard to Jordan for all of those
years. And I just liked
the guy. He was smooth.
He didn't make a big stink about
everything. He was in a showboater.
He got his teams to the NBA finals
twice in 90 against the Pistons in
[inaudible] 92 against, uh, the
bowls. And then in [inaudible] 91,
they made it to the western
conference finals against the Lakers.
He lost a couple of championships
and by the time he was,
he was really an old guy.
Uh, 32 years old. In 95,
he was traded to the Houston Rockets where
he had played for the Houston cougars
by Slamma Jamma with the Chemo Olajuwon.
Uh,
he was traded to Houston
and he won a championship.
That's my favorite team of all time.
Um,
so I don't know exactly how much is
going on with the blazers right now.
I don't want Lillard tall to overtake
Clyde though in all time. Blazers scoring.
So I'm hoping that's not going
to happen. Okay, there we go. Um,
I'm dying to take you and
Jordan out for a beer.
Let me know when you're going to be
in Vegas. I do a show on the strip.
I'd love to drink my crown
royal from your autograph Mug.
The autograph monk does go well with Crown
Royal. Um, we didn't make it to Vegas.
I don't know.
You know,
there's a couple of cities that people
have asked about that I'm not totally
sure why this or that didn't happen.
You know,
there's all sorts of considerations on
a tour that they try to figure out and I
don't know exactly what, uh, the answer,
but that was all right. Here we go.
I'm going to jump back to the, uh, to
the computer screen. We are trying to
get you people off. Patrion so
I'm going to hit refresh. Come on,
people tell me you dropped on Patrion
I don't want money on patrion 1756 and
1755.
This is going to be the longest.
This is going to be the live
stream from hell. People. Uh,
I'm trying to get you people to cancel.
I don't know what I can do.
I'm deleting it either way. So no matter
what happens at seven o'clock tonight,
a couple of minutes before seven,
I'll do it. Uh, you know, look,
I could leave this thing up and just
cash in on that and I could probably cash
in on it for a long time because
people sign up for things and forget.
I'm obviously not going to do that,
but I would love to see more
people cancel this thing at least.
But in the meantime, as we roll out
a whole bunch of this stuff, uh,
we are moving people over to my website.
So if you donate five bucks or more,
I'm giving you a shout out right now.
It's Dave ruby.com/donate 25 bucks or
more a month. You're getting a tee shirt,
50 bucks or more a month. You're
getting a signed autograph Mug and uh,
and yeah, let, let's do another shot of
petroleum. I'm feeling it at this point.
Let's make it happen. Let's
see. Uh, I just got here.
Are you aware of Youtube or laws,
FTC complaint,
he's working against Patrion and paypal.
Would you have them on your channel?
So I, I know of this video
and I've heard about this guy.
I actually haven't watched it yet.
Uh,
but it sounds like there might be some
legal issue related to collusion or
something like that.
Uh,
I need to know a little bit more about
it before I specifically comment on
anything.
Look,
my preference on all of these things
would not go be going through legal roots,
although sometimes there's
a need to do it. Uh, and,
and going through governmental force,
uh,
although I guess sometimes
perhaps there's a need to do it.
I know that sets bells off with
the libertarian set. Uh, my,
my preference would be that
human ingenuity and, and, uh,
creativity and the human
mind will resolve problems.
I think that's the way it's always been
done in the best ways and human history.
And I think that's what can
be done here. A mug time. Jim,
you're getting a mug. There you
go, Jim. Thank you very much.
Welcome to the team and a shout
out to Nicole. Thank you very much.
Let's see a super chat.
I got called a white supremacist.
All writer today for re tweeting Dave's
tweet about family guy self-censoring
gay jokes due to SJW pressure.
The world is upside down.
So if you haven't seen this,
I tweeted this yesterday,
there was an article in entertainment
tonight or one of these type of sites that
the producers of family guy have decided
that they're going to phase out gay
jokes. Now, uh,
I tweeted about this because I want you
to really think about how bananas is and
when people say,
oh,
there's SJW stuff doesn't matter in
this free speech stuff doesn't matter.
It's just happening on college campuses
and it's just a bunch of kids and all of
that. It, this is why it is
utter and complete nonsense.
We need humor to laugh at things.
We need the ability to release some steam.
Sometimes we need to be able to make fun
of people and sometimes groups and all
these
things. So to show that we're all equal,
watch it. Watch don Rickles do in comedy.
Go on Youtube later and
watch don Rickles do comedy.
And he made fun of everybody.
He made fun of Jews and gays and
Christians and white trash and Asians and
everybody. And it made everyone
in the audience realize, Whoa,
we're all part of the American experiment.
But what the left is doing by judging
us so intensely on our immutable
characteristics is these are the people
who are obsessed with our differences.
And they want us to be exactly the
same at the same time because they're,
their ideology has no logic. And that's
why they're so angry all the time.
And that's why they're so bitter and
resentful. And that's why they're,
they're always trying to d platform
people because they don't want to debate
ideas.
So the problem with this family
guy thing is that first off,
let's just put aside whether
family guys funny or any anymore.
It had a couple of good years for sure.
I really respect Seth Macfarlane.
Basically, I like the guy, I
think he's probably a decent guy.
He has made millions and millions,
maybe hundreds of millions of dollars.
I have no idea on being politically
incorrect. Think about the characters,
the old gay child molester that always
wants to molest Chris. Uh, more,
more. Goldman is the worst
Jewish stereotype you can
possibly imagine. Uh, the, uh,
the other two gay guys in the show, the
episode where Peter Becomes Gay. Um,
everything in everything in the show is a,
is an awful stereotype,
but it's, it's either funny
or it's not funny, but you,
that's up for you to decide
for them to say, ah, we've now,
and I'm not saying Seth made this
decision specifically and by the way,
I've invited him on the show many times.
I would love to sit them down,
sit down with him and I'm not judging
him specifically for this, but the, the,
the machine of family guy made a ton of
money being offensive to all sorts of
people and now you know,
we're in our twilight,
nobody really cares about us anymore.
No,
we're going to turn
against what we've done.
This is like when you see Sarah
Silverman now chide comedians for being
politically incorrect or I remember
when Milo's book was coming out,
she was a tweeting about that Simon and
Schuster should drop the books and now
we have comedians for getting
rid of books. That's pretty
close to book burning.
That's the modern sense of book burning
that has nothing to do with anyone's
feelings about Milo. Um, these
people have become hysterical and,
and the hectoring things that
they should be making fun of.
If George Carlin was alive today,
what do you think George Carlin
would be doing about that? Ideas?
He'd be mocking them.
Not demanding that we don't tell jokes
about certain things or we don't let
certain people publish books now.
That's the whole reason
I got back into stand up,
even though it was like the
last thing that I wanted to do.
I want people to see that you can laugh
about these things and guess what?
I go up there and I look around the crowd
and they make fun of everybody and in
that includes myself.
So I think we can fix this stuff.
But I think we can fix it through,
through comedy mostly. Um,
so come out to one of my stand up shows.
January 30th I'll be at the Irvine Improv,
a Dave ruby.com/events uh,
shout out to Jason. Thank you
very much. Um, uh, super chat.
Your biggest issue will be that
paypal, visa and mastercard. Uh,
sorry, I want to read this correctly.
Your biggest issue will be paypal,
visa and mastercard that force you
to shut down, not the backlash.
If you go 100% free speech,
no one can pay you then and that's
how you shut you down. So I,
I may have missed a word in there.
Um, okay, so this is an issue, right?
So if right now at [inaudible] dot com
slash donate, if you use your credit card,
you can donate through stripe,
which you, which is paypal,
you know it's credit card so you
can donate there. Any credit card.
It's a payment processor.
Um,
I have no reason to think that
stripe is going to get rid of me,
although they have gotten
rid of some other people.
But I have no reason to think
that's gonna happen to me.
But this isn't just
about me, obviously. Um,
I have no reason to think that paypal
is going to get rid of me. And again,
if just think about this for a second,
let's pretend you're right and you might
be right. If we're really worried that,
that someone like me,
let's say,
could actually potentially be stopped
from making financial transactions in the
United States,
then then think about the level of
tyranny we're really talking about.
And if you're saying that's here now,
well then again,
we better start talking about
this shit and fast. So, um,
I do think the answer is
partly lies within crypto.
We are now taking bitcoin on
right there below, uh, paypal and,
and the credit card thing. You can see
our bitcoin wallet, it's on there. Uh,
and as I said, we're, we're,
I'm also talking to a whole bunch of
other payment processors. There's ways,
there's creative ways people have figured
out to do all sorts of commerce online
and we're exploring all of those options.
So hang tight.
But if you are right and
if you're watching this and
you think that that guy's
comment might be right then man, we better
fix this quick. Otherwise we're, we're
really, we're far more screwed
than you might think. Uh, okay.
Um, I donated $5 a month and I
didn't get a shout out. I'm sad now.
Anyway. Best shooter ever is radiant
silver gun. It was a Saturn game.
I missed the Sega Saturn. Um, we
were doing shout outs. If you do it,
I'd Dave rubin.com/donate.
So you might've done it on super chat
cause that's where I just saw that.
So I don't, unfortunately,
I don't know your name. He
didn't say it there. Uh, okay.
Let's see. Let's see. Any News
on the Patriot and replacement?
My whole platoon at Fort Bliss,
Texas is wondering when you will
be in Texas next. Well, first off,
thank you guys for your service.
Most importantly,
um, did a whole bunch of shows what
you are in in Texas. Um, we did Dallas,
we did San Antonio, which I loved.
I had never been there before.
I've been to Dallas a bunch
of times. Um, we did Houston,
which was really cool to be,
and it was humid as fuck.
There it is hot in the summer in Houston.
Um, I will definitely be back there.
I think I'm going to do a public event
with a, with Glenn Beck at some point,
probably in the Dallas area, and I
should look into doing some standup in a,
in Texas. So hang tight on that. Uh,
okay. Let's see. Where are we at?
Please tell me we dropped at least two
people. You're killing me here. People.
What do we got on Patrion?
Right now we're at one seven
1,755 I'm clicking refresh.
All right. That's what I'm
talking about. Dropped six people,
but our money went up.
Our money went up.
Am I correct?
I am correct.
What was our money up before? And we
just went up like 1000 bucks on Patrion.
What the,
this is the Internet. This is as
internally as it gets. This is,
this is the Internet.
I am trying to lose money on Patriot
and our money on Patrion is going up.
Hmm.
You're funny. Whoever you did, whoever
you are, and I'm assuming it's one person
points for you. You know what?
You know what? This is messed up.
I don't want to do this,
but just because the person's
that's a high level of troll.
Who puts their money where their
mouth is. We, we know who it is.
We'll figure it out because you donate
it on Patrion so we get an email.
I'm giving you a mug even though that's
really messed up. You're getting a mug.
You're motherfucker. All right.
There you go. You're getting a mug.
The money's going up. The
ridiculous. All right guys.
We've got about 40 minutes left
I a little bit before seven.
I will delete Patriot and no
matter I can be a $25,000 a month.
We're going to delete this thing.
Uh,
I do not know what to say to
people like you. Um, let's see.
Uh,
th the book,
the coddling of the American
mind is an amazing book.
It's a must read during these
times. While I've had a, Oh,
that's Jonathan Haidt who I've
had on the show years ago.
We almost had them back on two weeks ago.
He was in la,
but we couldn't quite work it out.
I will definitely get him back on.
Hang on that, uh, March in. Thank you.
Is that my old friend marching from,
from New York. Could that
be, could that be him?
I used to have an old buddy marching,
m a R C I n in New York. Is that him?
Could that be you? You gotta sign Mug my
friend. Oh, I think you just did a shadow,
but you know what? You're
probably getting a mug. Uh,
cause I read that off the wrong
thing. Uh, okay. Let's see.
Um, uh, $99 and 99 cents.
Take a shot. Love you Dave. Mad
respect. You know what? For doing 99, 99
shot a patroned for you. There
you go. We don't mess around here.
This is a pretty big shot. Glass to a. All
right, we're going to get a little salt.
Here we go.
All right.
Little Salt. Oh, patrol.
I like Tequila. I do like Tequila. I'm a,
I'm a red wine drinker. As most of you
guys really know. I like Napa reds mostly.
Um, or northern calorie reds. Um, oh,
I really like Italian reds lately,
so I really only drink wine,
but I do like Tequila when
it, when it comes around. Um,
I think it's a different Martin,
he was known as Martin even
though it was Marson or marching,
but I believe it's a different
marching. But hello march.
And how are you? Um, okay.
Uh, bad boys. Pistons versus up and
coming Bowles was my favorite NBA time.
Made you laugh?
The Ginger Mary
a question. That was the point. All
right. There you go. Uh, yeah. You know,
I hated those pistons. The
bad boys Pistons. They to
me, that was in basketball.
I hated bill Laimbeer.
They also beat my blazers in 1990,
which was a very underrated series.
All the games were within two or
three points. And one of the Games,
I think it was game three, the
game three, it was game mode.
I think it was game four or five.
Danny young who is a scrub backup on the
blazers. He hit a shot at half court,
that would've got the game into overtime.
That A, they waved off at the Buzzer. Uh,
but it was a, it was a great
series. Um, shout out to Ricardo.
Welcome on board Ricardo. Um, let's see.
Uh,
is Ian McGilchrist on your radar yet?
His book is enlightening in the way it
explores how we're divided brain alters
behavior, culture and society. Given
the name sounds vaguely familiar. Um,
but I can't say he fully has. Guys, can
we put Ian Mcgilchrist on the list? Um,
100 bucks. This is the weirdest
pledge drive I've ever seen. Lol.
This is, I'm trying to lose money
in effect at some level, I suppose.
And we're gaining, if I press this right
now and there's more money in there,
I'm actually going to punch the camera.
Here we go.
We have 1,749 patrons,
$10,620.
All right, let's see it
drop. Let's see it drop.
Wait a minute. What happened
there? We lost five.
We lost $5 people. That's what
I'm talking about. Lost $5.
How many people did we lose their
couple of people. We lost $5.
Whatever you do please,
people,
I implore you for the sake of free speech
in America for the future of the First
Amendment, do not donate a
patrion.com/ruben report. I'm deleting it.
Don't go there. Go there to delete,
but don't go there for anything else.
We got in this thing. It's a nightmare.
A shout out to Kim. Thank you very much,
Kim.
Uh,
I'm starting to wish you chose January
for your annual social media blackout.
That's funny. That's funny. I do
August off the grid. You know,
I'm going to really push
I think this year, uh,
as many people as possible to join me
on this thing. I do a 30 day cleanse.
I mean, that's the only way I can describe
it. Completely off the grid. No phone.
I locked my phone in a safe, which I
don't know the code to a no television,
which it's almost impossible
to avoid television.
It's really hard to avoid news because,
hey,
you got to tell everybody that
you're not listening to the news.
Because I try not to get anything
in my brain during that, you know,
I'm doing other things,
but I try not to get the day to day
news in my brain because it's just,
we're just endlessly hit with information.
I don't think this is the way we were
always wired to be. Maybe it's the future,
it's the next evolution of being a human.
But I don't think it's supposed
to be like this all the time. Um,
but I realized the hardest part of being
off the grid is that everywhere that
there is a muted television,
there is CNN, every airport,
muted television, CNN, every burger,
joint, muted television, CNN,
you go to the gym, you did
television, CNN, if you will.
I don't know that anyone's listening
to CNN with the words, which would be,
it's hilarious if you
do. Um, but, uh, yeah,
I highly recommend doing a
little off the grid thing.
I try to do it on the weekends too,
to the best degree that I can. Not as,
not as strictly as I did in, in
August, but this, this August.
I think I'm going to try to get as
many people as possible to do it.
A shout out to Keith. What are we
doing here guys? Quick reset. Uh,
we're moving everybody off patrion
and we're trying to get people to Dave
rubin.com/donate it is the first of
about five steps over the next couple of
months that I'm doing.
Two just to get true independence to
have true sort of ownership over our
content and audience and the rest of it,
we're going to remain fully funded
by you guys, which is fantastic.
I have no boss, no one has ever told
me anything to do or say on this show.
We do what we want.
I do what I think is right for,
for all the positives and
negatives of all of that.
So we are doing a little fundraising
here today and then deleting Patrion 25
bucks. You're getting the last
remaining Ruben report. Uh,
Patriot on select tee shirts and a,
I'm going to sign a Mug for
ya for $50 or more. A month.
Shout out to Raymond. Thank
you very much. Hey Dave,
is Gillette the best a man can get?
I mean Juliette's like I've just had it
with you people. You know what I mean?
It's like you don't have to turn on half
the people to bow to the social justice
God.
You don't have to make men look toxic and,
and it's just ridiculous.
Pandering idiocy. And you know,
it's interesting there's
this meme of go get woke,
go broke implying that the companies
are going to fail because of this.
I don't know that that's actually true.
Maybe they are making more
money because of this,
but it's not good and it's not right.
And guess what?
I don't give a shit about the politics
of the company. I get my razors from,
although I can tell you that going forward
I would go out of my way not to buy a
Gillette product for sure. It's
like Ben and Jerry's did that, uh,
resist ice cream. I don't even think Ben
and Jerry's is that good anymore. Um,
I really like McConnell's ice cream,
which is a,
a creamery in Santa Barbara up here. I
don't know that they're all over. They're,
they're nationwide,
but if you live in the California area
and probably west coast Mcconnell's ice
cream is awesome.
They got a,
they got a cookies and cream
that is fantastic and a sea
salt something or other.
That is amazing. But anyway,
it's like, all right,
if you guys are putting all in that
we're going in Hashtag resist. It's like,
I just don't want to give you my money.
And then people will say, well Dave,
you're a hypocrite because
you still eat a chick filet.
It was like Chick-fil-a isn't putting,
we're four.
We're against gay marriage
on their chicken sandwiches.
The owner once gave a couple of hundred
bucks to some anti gay marriage thing or
something to that effect.
It's like, who cares?
People are allowed to do private things
in their private lives and it's like you
guys think that if you could only control
the way everybody thinks and the way
everyone behaves,
that the world would be better and I
think the world would actually be much
worse.
I don't care what anyone does or thinks
as long as they don't do it to me or on
my property, just don't touch
me. That's really all I ask.
Let's go to Patrion and watch this thing
dump out because I know you people are
canceling for me.
So right now we're at
1,747 were at $10,615
please have dropped.
We're up $52
look,
I get what the Internet is. You
know I get it. You're funny.
You're funny people having a good time.
You know watching the livestream,
you know watching the youtube or
do youtube, you're killing me.
I have to leave this thing.
I have to go.
Please stop putting money there. You
think this is funny. This is funny.
This is my life.
50 bucks on super chat. Signed
the Mug to my wife. Just fee fee.
So you in Orlando and loved it and Doby
was slammed that Tequila like we do in
Texas.
All right fee you're getting a mug fees.
Getting a mug fee is a great lady fee.
F E and I'm putting an
exclamation point for her.
Cause I feel good about fee
and I'm signing in the Mug. Uh,
that Orlando show was one of my favorite
shows. I, I say it, all of that.
A lot of the shows that I use,
and I do mean it when I say it,
that Orlando show is fantastic.
That theater was gorgeous.
I think those Disney,
it was like the Disney something theater.
I think the Disney people are going
to be okay financially by the way. Um,
that was a great, great,
great, great show.
We did four shows in four
nights in Florida and that,
that Orlando one has stuck the
ones that really stuck out with me.
The Atlanta one, cause it was Jordan's
birthday. Uh, Orlando was amazing.
Grand rapids, Michigan I think might've
been the best show we did. And,
and the first time we were in Calgary
we blew the roof off the place.
It was actually legitimately crazy.
It was, it was bananas. Mockers.
Shout out terrain, man. Thank
you very much. Okay. Um,
thanks for standing on principle
Dave. Yeah, my pleasure.
Um, do you think there is hope to
end this far left path that we're on?
First of all, I got to take
some water. I'm choking so
I cannot believe people are still
donating to patriot. This is like,
I feel like I'm in green. I'm going to
actually you an episode of Black Mirror.
This is black mirror. This is it.
We're in Bandersnatch right now.
You guys are picking my future. You know
what I mean? Like we're, this is bananas.
Um, the question was, um,
what the hell was the question?
Oh, there was a question there.
What,
what?
It's there. Ah, do you think there's,
there's an end to the far
left path where I look,
this thing has to implode
one way or another.
The question is how bad will it get
before it implodes and how much power it
will attain before it implodes. The that
is, that is the true question here. When,
when Cortez or some of these people talk
about 70% marginal tax rate and then
people scream all that, they should
have it and your role, they don't,
they're not going to take 70% of your
money. They mean above $10 million. Now,
let's pretend now I don't
make $10 million. I don't
make $1 million a year. Let's
pretend for a second that, um,
that you made $10 million a year.
Let's pretend you made $20 million
person watching this right now.
You figured out how to do something.
You created something of value,
something you made up a product. You made
a candy bar, you made a video game, you,
you sold a wine. You are an
incredibly successful locksmith.
Whatever the hell you are,
you're not making $15 million a year.
Now basically the federal government,
when you're making that much money,
you're in the top 1%. Let's say, um,
I'm just doing rough numbers here.
The government is going to tax you at
basically 37% right now at that point.
Now, if you own your own business,
you can write off some stuff.
And let's say you can get that down to
about 30% what she's proposing is that
over $10 million that you take in the
government should take 70% of that now for
young people and the Socialists crew
of America, that all sounds good.
You don't need that money. You don't
deserve that money. You didn't build that.
All of those things and it just
sounds right. It sounds right,
like you should give back more.
Why do you need that much money?
Except that has nothing to do
with truth or what's right.
What right does someone
have because they feel,
because some government bureaucrat
feels that they should take from you who
created to give to someone who did not
create, even if their intentions are good,
what gives them the right to do it?
I would say they have no right to do it,
but this is the new left and some would
argue this is the old left like some old
school gave me. I think if Prager was
sitting here or Shapiro, they'd say,
this is what it always was.
I don't know that it always was this
way because I think there used to be a
decent left. And I think it's important
that we have a decent left once again.
Um, this is a horrible set of ideas and
that's not just the only part of this,
that's a horrible set of ideas. The
fact that Tamika allow, uh, Mallory,
who was one of the leaders of the
women's March, was on the view yesterday,
the day before and couldn't
condemn outright. Louis Farrakhan,
who calls Jews cockroaches and a zillion
other things. And he's also met with,
um, what's her name up in California. Um,
the other Congress woman, I'm blanking
on her name for a second. Um, and all,
all of these people, they're in
bed with a lot of bad people. Um,
and you can see this thing coming in a
judges us all in our worst ways and it,
and it believes, it believes that
the state is the ultimate power.
And think of the irony of this. Trump
is in charge. These are the pain,
the same people who think that
Trump is a Russian asset and that,
and if you agree that
Trump is a Russian asset,
and I say this as someone that
did not even vote for Trump,
but if you believe that
Trump is a Russian asset,
you actually think were
world war three right now.
What could be a higher declaration
of war than having the,
having installed the president
of the United States?
So if you think it's a good idea that
we should impeach the president or
something to that effect,
or if you think really that Russia
installed the president of United States,
then understand what the pat, what you
believe is the path to world war three.
Now, if they did install the
president then all right,
I guess we're on path to world war
three or could this just be a bunch of
paranoid lunacy for a bunch of people
who were in power, in lost power.
And that's why I would say that the best
answer to any of this is limited power
limit power. And that what that
means is that when your guys empower,
not that much will change, but guess what?
It's pretty damn good in America. Yeah,
it is.
And then what that also means is when
the guy that you don't like is empowered,
not that much bad can change. And guess
what? It's pretty good in America.
So that's the negotiation to live
in a free, stable Western society.
You can move on the margins. But when,
when Cortez gets out there and says,
I'm going to tax these people at 70%
and says to Joe Lieberman, who this,
you're the future.
You're the past.
It's like you think that basically a
bartender thinks that she knows how to run
the world.
And by the way,
if you think that she's the one really
tweeting all of this stuff or that there
isn't a whole congregation of people
that decide what she can tweet,
I think you're sorely mistaken.
But again,
I will 100% be glad to interview her and
treat her with the exact same respect I
would treat any other guests. We will air
it live. I won't even do use questions.
I will sit here with nothing and
other than myself and talk to her.
I would be happy to do that.
Okay,
let's go back to the patriarchy
thing and please, for God's sakes,
people please tell me there's no more
money there. This is a nightmare.
We're in black mirror.
We have 1,740 by below 10,666 $7
oh, you mother fuckers. This
is fucked up. All right. We're,
we're entering a fucked up bays.
Okay. That's where we're at.
We're getting to a place where this is
not good and nobody's happy about this,
Huh? Huh, Huh? Uh, it's
not good. It's not. What?
Why are you doing this?
This is the Internet.
This is the Internet. We're here.
We're on the Internet. We're doing it.
I'm trying to cancel this thing.
I don't like this company.
I don't want them to
have any more success.
I'm trying to stick a line in the sand
and you people think it's hilarious.
You people, well, Juliette, you're
getting a mug. Thank you very much,
and thank you for donating@daverubin.com
slash donate instead of Patrion.
They're no good.
They don't like free speech.
They're getting 5% of your money. You
people who are doing this now to be funny,
we got 24 more minutes and then I'm
pressing delete on this freaking thing.
Super Chat.
200 bucks.
They want me to do a shot day by enjoyably
spent hours trying to figure out what
is going on within each of your
studios. Paintings. I love them.
I love hearing that. So, so all of
my paintings are not all of them,
but most of the paintings. So this
one right here, which is a great,
it's about three foot by five
foot. Uh, this is an original,
this is an absolute original.
This is done by Caitlin. Janet.
You can go to Kaitlyn rose,
Janet see a y l I n rows,
janet.com.
She's an artist who has
done some amazing stuff, uh, in my house.
Almost everything in my house is from her.
This painting,
which we commissioned just for,
uh, just for the set obviously, um,
is, Eh, I wish I could explain it in
a proper sense. If you go to her site,
I think you, she explains the process
there. She knows how much I love coffee.
So there's actual coffee
grinds in the painting,
which is what's giving it some
of the texture over there.
And I wanted something that
felt a little futuristically.
So that's why you're
getting those stark lines.
And then I want it to feel like a little
bit less, sort of like the universe and,
and sort of messy and, and interesting.
So, hey, that's her in it. Aaron,
if we can go to the guests shot right
now, the regular guest shot, uh,
the painting on the other side.
If we can go to that one.
I'm not sure we can right now. We
can't go to that one right now. Oh,
we can't write because we moved
the camera. That's right. Um,
she did the one on the other side that
you'd normally see behind the guests head.
I'm also on her site. You can see
she, we, she did an incredible,
it's four foot by five foot,
um,
hyperspace so the Millennium
Falcon going into hyperspace,
she did an original forest.
She painted it over days in our house,
which was a freaking crazy labor of love.
She had to make a protractor using
a string in a piece of wood. Uh,
she's an incredible, incredible arts and
you get principal all of these on there.
I don't get a penny for him and she's
just wonderful artists. I, Kaitlyn rose,
jan.com. Okay. Um, you know what you,
because you asked about the paintings,
he gave 200 bucks. All right,
I'm going to do a shot.
I hope you're happy and please people
stop donating at patrion.com/rubin report.
I've got a life to live. I've got to
end this thing and this nightmare,
this Bandersnatch now, I
mean a, I mean it's the,
I mean this is what the Internet is.
I'm in the choose your own adventure
venture of the Internet. All right,
here we go. All right. You want the
other guy wanted me to do this fast.
So here we go. Here's this
like we do it in Texas. Is that
there's that.
There's that.
All right.
Love you Dave.
Super Chat. I love you Daniel.
You're getting a shout out,
a superchat hook a brother up with the
mug. Please come back to Atlanta soon.
How'd I do that? That was pretty good.
Hook a brother. He's a B. R. O. T. H. J.
Hook a brother at the, I'd
be like, I did good on that.
You got it. A superchat. Yes.
Orlando is the best comeback soon.
I would love to come back. I love,
I love all of those.
Uh,
the Disney lands and your universal
studios and things like that.
We got him here to a super jack. Thanks
for standing on principle, Dave. Yeah.
You know what?
I guess what's cool actually right now,
despite the fact that people
keep giving me money on Patrion,
even though I asked you not to,
is that I'm standing over
something that I believe in. I'm a,
I'm having a ton of fun right now. This
is kind of fun and I'm a little drunk,
but like beyond all of that, it's
like, guess what? When you stay,
this is what I quoted Douglas before.
When you dare get in the pool,
you might find out that the water's not
that cold. And that I think is the truth.
I think what you guys
are seeing right now,
I've got people all over the world in
super chats and kind of unpatriotic you
motherfuckers and,
and all over the place that are,
that are giving me money, having fun,
enjoying watching this. And it's just
because I stood up for what I believe.
And I think you can do it too.
Like maybe the truth does set you free.
Who somebody must have said that,
right? Somebody said that. Um, Dave,
serious question.
Are there any creators on Patrion that
you're disappointed having joined the
patriarch purge? Um, no,
no. Go the answer to know everyone
has their own considerations.
I want to be very clear about that.
Someone tweeted me about this
today and I retweeted with comment.
Someone said something to
the effect of, Oh, you know,
Sam Harris deleted his
immediately and you and Jordan,
it's been a couple of weeks and you're
tweeting about it and blah, blah blah.
And it's like I, first off, I think
you guys know my feelings about Sam.
I have nothing but respect for him.
He's a good friend and I have
admiration and love for the guy.
I don't know exactly what his business
considerations are. So he was able to,
I don't know what his personal finances
are or anything or anything else. I just,
I I genuinely don't know for as well as
I know him. He deleted his on principle.
I have truly nothing but respect for that.
I have a different situation here in that
I have a company that I'm running that
most of the money of the income from the
company was coming from our fan funding.
Okay.
So we have different considerations.
Jordan has different
considerations as well.
You guys have different feelings about
all of us about where you want to spend
your hard earned money and I do believe
it is your hard earned money. Um,
so anyone that's on there,
whether Brett staying on there right
now or Colin staying on their sword and
scales on their whole bunch of
other people I think are doing,
doing good stuff and trying to fight the
fight the same way that I'm trying to
fight it for all I know.
Maybe Jordan and I leaving,
maybe the people at Patriot on right now,
look,
I know a bunch of cowards and error,
probably looking around going, oh,
I hope nobody notices that.
I actually liked Dave and Jordan and I'm
not a programmed robot in an NPC, but,
but there are people there
that are probably happy that
the headache of Peterson
and Ruben and Harris has gone.
Um,
but I don't make my decisions based on
who might think I'm a headache. So, um,
so that's that.
And as I said,
maybe those guys will be able to change
things from the inside. You anything,
anything that's a movement
that that matters. Um,
people do it in different ways.
People did the civil rights
movement in different ways.
Some people wanted to do it one way.
Some people want to do another. Any,
anything that matters. And I truly
believe we're in a battle for free speech.
And if some people say you have to
stay inside the institutions and fight,
some people want to fight from the
outside. It's like, it's all good.
It's all good. These people are
my allies and my friends and,
and I mean allies in the best sense of it.
Not,
I don't mean ally because
they bow to me forever.
If there is more money on Patrion right
now, I'm going to, I'm going to, um,
well it's not going to be pretty people.
Here we go.
I am trying to cancel this thing.
I'm going to 10,000,
$895,
1,745 patrons please for the love of God.
Let those numbers be going down.
They're up.
They're up again. We went up to
people and we went up about 20 bucks.
Is that right?
I hope you're happy.
Uh, okay. Can't afford 50 bucks because
I'm saving for a psychology Grad school.
After discovering my
interest through Jordan.
And any chance I could get a
leftover mug if there is one, uh,
Star Wars episode nine. No hope.
All right, let's first of all,
let's give this guy a mug.
I'll sign it right now.
Can we get any know we have to
figure out how to get your email.
So hopefully that can be tied
into your, uh, your super dress.
I will gladly give you a mug. No
problem. Uh, episode nine. No, no hope.
So I'm glad you asked this question
because let's talk about something else
besides,
um, free speech and the rest of it
for just a sec. So, so, uh, so David,
my husband had a little, a, a minor
surgery over the last couple of days,
which on top of it, as busy as
we've been about a zillion things,
I've also had his brother and sister in
law here and his mom here and everyone's
been taking care of him and I've been
trying to do the best that I can do two
and, and everything else.
He's completely fine.
He's going through a little recovery
right now. It's all good. Um,
but he had a little time to watch TV.
We watched the prequels.
Now I've been saying for a couple of
years now that I think years from now the
prequels are going to be
looked at very fondly,
very differently than their looked
at. Now. Is the acting bad? Yes.
Is the script stiff?
Yes,
but is the story of those prequels of
what the accumulation of power and then
the flipping of power because
that's really what it's about.
It's an incredible personal story of
the development of Vatican Skywalker,
but what it's really about is that the
emperor Palpatine was accumulating,
accumulating,
accumulating power through political
processes through creating crisises that
then at the last moment, I mean this is
what revenge of the system SIF is about.
He then a Qa has enough power
to get rid of the opposition.
That's sort of what we're
dealing with right now.
It's an incredible political story
at the, uh, what's his name? Hey,
in Christian's a horrible actor.
Natalie Portman is a terror is
absolutely terrible in this.
I'm not a big fan of hers anymore
for a couple of political reasons,
but I grew up in the same
town as her actually,
and we went to the same high school.
Um, I'm sure she's a lovely woman,
but I'm not, not a huge fan of the
moment. Um, but anyway, I think people,
if you look at the, the prequels
and they're missing little moments,
like we needed to know who count
dookoo was a little bit more,
they needed to tell us a little bit more
about [inaudible] and why he went to
the cloners originally.
A couple little things,
but if you remove some of that stuff,
the stories are actually great.
Force awakens I think
is a fantastic movie.
I think Jj Abrams did an incredible
lift of resetting the entire thing and,
and last Jedi is just horrendous. It's
horrendous at every level. Purple hair.
And Laura Dern, why wasn't that Admiral
Ackbar at his last moment of glory?
Instead you killed him off camera layer.
There's no force in space.
Who the hell smoke now? Ray has
no parents. What's his name? Uh,
fn two eight one seven.
Finn has no point in the whole movie,
his whole adventure that he goes
on at the casino with the SJW girl,
they have no point in the movie.
They fail and then it just,
they just end up back there with dementia
and then the movie is absolute crap.
Luke is a grumpy old fool.
Why at that point is he force project
himself there instead of showing up to the
final battle if he was going to die either
right and let the guy freaking die in
a blaze of glory. The whole
thing was lazy. It was a resume.
I think Ryan Johnson basically
is resentful of wars.
All that being said, uh, I think JJ can
fix it for episode nine and I really,
I really, really, really, really,
really, really, really hope that he does.
We shall see. Uh, all right, I can do
it. I think I can do two more shots.
We got 15 minutes.
I think I can do two more shots.
So it's going to have to be
200 bucks on a, on any format.
So whether it's a patrion no, not
patriotic. CanNot be patriotic.
No patriotic people are not
new. A patriot. Okay. Uh,
I can do two more shots, but you have
to do in a Dave rubin.com/donate.
You can do it on paypal. You do it
on credit card. You do it on bitcoin.
I don't care at this point.
Please do not do it on Patriot.
A shout outs to Herschel shout
outs to Bannon and a Mug for Jacob.
Herschel Bannon. Jacob, we
just went to a shtetl in a,
in Poland in 1860. All
right, there you go brother.
I signed that one on the front
for you. That's a rare one. Jacob,
you're getting one on the front. Uh,
exasperated. Reuben is the best. Reuben,
I love you man. Okay. Uh,
donating 10 bucks towards having Matt
Christiansen on the Ruben where we will do
that. A bunch of you have asked. We
will do that for sure. Um, let's see.
Dave,
please briefly remind the newly joined
viewers how they can support you since
you're moving away from patron. I think
I've been trying to do that. Dave,
room and.com/donate.
We are building out several things.
We are rebuilding my website,
it is going to be completely insulated
from censorship on the video hosting
front on the platform hosting
front on the monetization front.
That is just one step of getting away
from Patriot on these third party people
who don't live up to the
ideals that I live up to.
I am not asking the government
to get involved. Um,
and that is one step onto building a
platform and then several other steps down
the road. I promise you, this is just
the beginning of several markers.
We're going to do something cool here.
Like why not right? Like I'm alive.
You're alive. Let's do it. Okay. Uh,
200 bucks. No comment with donation,
but time for another shot.
You all right?
Here we go.
Yeah,
getting too old for this shit.
You know what I mean? Here we go.
Patroned for Patriot.
Woo.
And now wait a little jelly spoons.
I'm going to click
refresh on the page here.
Here we go.
Right now we have 1,747 people
were getting $10,904 please,
if there is a god in the universe,
let that number go down.
We went up $4.
Are you happy for a dollar per person?
You know what I mean?
Okay.
Oh God, another 200 no, that
house. All right, hold on.
I, I literally can't do another shot
right now. Um, I'm a red wine drinker too,
and I'd love to do a celebrative shy
with you. Keep up all the great work.
Cheers to beautiful future.
I'll display by bug one shelf higher
than my Michael knolls sign leftist tear
your mug
tumbler. I appreciate that. Very nice.
Stick it to that Knowles guy
that rightwing maniac that.
All right, maniac. Yeah.
Talk about you.
No holes. Uh, $50 in Canadian dollars.
Can I get a mug?
I mean,
what is 50 Canadian dollars worth in
American [inaudible] what are we six,
seven bucks? I don't know what I
can do for that guy. Um, 20 bucks.
Let's get Dave over $11,000
on Patriot and no, no,
you're not good.
You're not a good person.
What's your thought on
the Captain Marvel movie?
I haven't tracked this thing at all,
but I know what's her name's in it.
Brie Larson. I think
she's a good actress. Um,
but is it connected to Avengers?
It is.
Right then she's going to have
some big role in Avengers.
Infinity war by the way,
was phenomenal.
I have been on a lot of planes in the
last couple months. I've seen infinity.
It's about 20 times.
And I,
Eh, Eh, there is perfect. It's pretty
much perfect as a superhero movie. Um,
it's so worth donating to your telephone
to watch you load up on Tequila,
love you and your spirit on spirits.
Way To upstage,
poke in a hockey puck in hockey,
love from Jamie and Janine,
Po poke in a Honky poky and hockey,
whatever it is that you wrote there.
I feel like it was something that I
should have understood and I probably just
said it wrong, but I
thank you for that. Um,
when the Patriot and replacement is up,
will it be announced on the subscribed
star site or we'll be at via mass social
media explosion. And what do you think
about the women's March controversy?
All right.
The women's March thing,
I think it's pretty obvious. Look, the
intersectional oppression Olympics thing,
it's crumbling because they
literally are like, wait a minute.
How can we treat Jews? Sure. They've
been programmed in Holocaust,
did and, and, and been
in the other, in the,
in the law for the longest
history of anything.
But now they're kind of successful over
the last 50 years, especially in America.
How should we treat them despite
the fact there might be Brown?
My brother in law happens to be a brown
Jew. Um, how should we treat these people?
This is the essence of what
collectivism is. It is the new racism,
progressives or the new races races.
If you want to see something incredible.
By the way, look at my Twitter from
about, I think three or four tweets ago.
Uh, David Webb, who is a conservative
who happens to be black, was not doing,
I'm doing his, uh, Fox nation
show, I think a on Thursday.
He was on, uh, he was doing, it
was either he show or another show.
I'm actually not sure, uh,
because I had such a crazy day.
I was just catching these little clips
he was on with the Rebbe Martin or read
Martin. Happens to be a lovely
woman who's also a black,
she's been on my show years ago.
She's a progressive.
They get on the show together.
They're doing so she doesn't know.
She apparently she didn't know
who he was or anything about him.
He goes on and on about something
and then she goes, well,
you're showing your white privilege.
This literally happened today and David
Webb, who is a black conservative,
who is a really great guy who I've
drank a lot of freaking bourbon with,
that he usually pays for it. That's
extremely expensive. He goes, well,
a river.
Do you know that I'm black?
And then you gotta listen
to the rest of this.
It's incredible because
progressivism is the new racism.
Understand this. If you understand
this, you will almost be able,
that is almost the key.
You need to unlock almost everything
that's happening in America,
the people that are peddling racism that
we'll want to institutionalize racism,
who want white people to bow to them and
who hate Christianity and all and who
hate anything that's remotely
traditional or conservative.
And I save this as a gauge.
You, you know what I mean?
I don't say this as one of these people
that are trying to push anyone to
believe anything. Um, this is what
this thing has become and it's,
and it's seriously dangerous and crazy.
It is six 50
the two.
I am going to check this thing and I
don't like anyone that has gone on to this
freaking thing or we're getting into
dangerous territory. Where's my mouse?
Mouse is a mouse actually technically
is this thing of mouse. All right.
1,749 people right now have
donated $10,900 a month.
That is used to be around 35,000 and a
lot of you have quit and I thank you for
that. Thank you for stop giving
me money. I appreciate it.
I'm going to hit refresh on this and I
hope that that number has gone down and
if it hasn't gone down, you've put me
in some sort of foster and bargain.
Here we go.
I don't think I pressed it properly.
Oh my God. It went up
again, didn't it? What?
We went down,
we went down to $18
thank you.
Thank you,
Internet.
We went down to $18 I've been talking
for two hours and finally after imploring
people to stop giving
me over $10,000 a month,
we lost $9 $18 we lost $80.
That's incredible. Shout outs to
Andrew and Theresa and to Sam.
I appreciate it. Jim. You're
getting a Mug, brother. All right,
Jim, you're a good man, guys.
Would it be completely insane?
I'm tempted to do this just
because I cannot believe this,
but I want to get the
thumbs up from my team.
I'm looking through the window here.
Uh,
would it be insane to extend this for
a half hour? It would not be insane.
I've been given the thumbs up. Yeah,
everyone's confirming this. All right,
here's the deal. I'm going to
continue this for a half hour. I,
I genuinely cannot believe
this is happening. Please.
People, Internet people.
Why? But this is true. This is real.
You freaks. Uh, Oh God. Another 200 bucks.
Drink Canada 50 is $37 and 68 cents
in the u s can I get a Canadian mug?
Oh No. Can I get a can of Canadian
and got a bug? That's very different.
Can I get a Canadian mug? That's
more, what is it? Canadian mug.
How is that different than an American
Mug? Can the Canadian get a Mug?
No, you got to do it monthly.
You can't do it on super chat.
You're taking advantage of the
situation person, Canadian person, uh,
$50. Should we be supporting Dave
mugging people? Good question. Uh,
what percentage of your listeners
do you speculate or women?
So it's actually interesting.
So I don't know the total answer to
this because when you do audio podcasts,
which actually our audio
podcast is actually,
I think almost more popular than
the youtube show at this point. Um,
which is bizarre because
no one sees those numbers.
So it's a weird thing cause you
sort of judged the popularity, uh,
in terms of, uh, in terms
of the youtube numbers. Um,
last I saw our, our,
so politics in general,
if you talking about anything
political excuse mail,
now I know that the social justice
warriors, we'd love it to have to be 50,
50 men and women should care about the
exact same things at the exact same time
no matter what. Let's put that
aside for just a second. Um,
generally politics skews
heavily now. I mean, it's crazy.
It's something like 90 10.
Our channel is mostly politics,
obviously are mostly culture, cultural
related to politics, let's say.
Um, I think we're at about 75, 25,
so I think it's about 75% male,
25% female,
which is pretty evenly
distributed relative to the
topics we're talking about.
So it's a little hard to say.
Uh,
someone just donated
50 bucks on super chat.
Neither Reuben Mug to sit
next to my left is tear monks.
But you got to go to Dave
rubin.com/donate. We're not
doing that for super shy.
You got to do it.
You got to do it monthly.
It's just one of the things we had to do.
I appreciate it. Thank you. All right.
You know what, we'll do it
for that guy, but I cannot,
we can't do it for anyone else.
So if we can get that guy's email address,
if we can possibly get it.
Um,
$42,000 for 42,000 coast guard
members still required to work,
did not get a paycheck for the first
time in us history that the military were
not paid. Where your,
your opinion. All right,
this will be a lot to get into
at this at this moment. Um,
what I would say is this,
is that first off it sounds like,
and I think this is a bipartisan thing,
which is bizarre these days.
It sounds like everyone
that's furloughed right now,
we're not getting paid right now.
That works for the government.
We'll get back pay. So that's
one thing. Now of course,
that doesn't deal with your
immediate bills. Now, if
you work for the government,
shouldn't you be living in a
situation where your week to week?
Probably not and maybe,
maybe you have to figure out a few
things for your own life. But we,
we've all done that. When I was a
struggling comic, I swear on my life,
I remember a day when I, I, first of all,
I was late on rent and I was
barely making anything. And I had,
I had quit several jobs and I had done
for attending and I had done promotions
and I had handed out shit on the streets
and I've done all sorts of things.
And I remember, and this is, I was
already in my mid twenties or something,
like I was way past this point
and I moved in. I didn't,
I couldn't even afford an apartment
anymore. And I moved in, uh,
three guys who were great guys,
I'll give him a shadow is
Mike and Chris and Adam,
they didn't even have an
extra room in their apartment.
They had a basically a whole way with a
cot and they let me stay there for like,
I think it was like 50 bucks a month to
live in New York City and I remember one
day I had no cash.
Like I literally had no cash and I did
not know what to do and I was struggling
comic and the whole thing and blah
blah blah. I'm not even saying this,
cry me a river. I went into Mike's room.
Mike is still a good buddy of mine. Mike,
if you're watching this and there's a good
chance you are and I love you brother,
I guess is a good time to tell Ya.
I took 75 cents from your change jar.
Chock full of nuts change here.
You had an old chocolate nuts
like metal coffee can dare.
I took 75 cents and maybe I took
95 cents and I went to Zabar's.
We lived on the upper west side.
I went to Zabar's,
which everyone that's been to New York
City knows about gay bars and then I got
a cup of coffee and I
stole change for you.
I felt so freaking guilty for doing that.
Um,
so the struggle is real,
I guess is the point of that.
What was the point of that? I don't really
remember. Okay. Different marching, uh,
seeing you in the UK during June.
Jordan Peters has talk.
Hope to see you again here soon. Good luck
outside. Patrion right on brother. Um,
longtime fan.
Just want to say you're awesome.
Pledging to you and Jordan on payday.
Ever need to design writing worker
or a VA work. Uh, I'm your Gal.
Much love why I appreciate it
and walked back out. Yeah. Yeah.
We've had so many people offer to work
for us for free and offer to donate
skills and this or that.
We're trying. I have a,
what I do is every time I get an email
where someone else is offering us
something or some skillset or something,
I forwarded to Helen who's my assistant,
who is an incredible actually and has
been a godsend in this operation who we
hired back in September. Who, by the
way, I think I'm allowed to say this.
Uh, she over the last eight or 10 years
of his life was Hugh Hefner's assistance.
So that's actually pretty cool.
My assistant right now is
you have nursing assistant.
So if I start wandering around in robes
with a lot of hot chicks around me,
you'll know why, uh, in any event, uh,
I forward everything over to her and
she's compiling a list of all of these
things. So we'll try to figure out a lot
of this, uh, what to do going forward.
All right, we got, we got
a half hour left, so with,
and I'm not extending it after that. This
is ridiculous and I hate all of you. Uh,
I'm going to press refresh here
and I just want to say please,
for the love of God,
we want to end this thing tonight.
1,749 of you for some reason have
refused to cancel your patriotic gowns.
$10,000, 800, 10,000, $890 or
sitting in there. Here we go.
Yeah, we lost, we lost
about a thousand bucks.
Goodnight everybody.
Thank you.
Thank you for deleting $1,000 of
patronage. I couldn't be happier.
Thank you so much. You are great
people. You are great. Great people. Uh,
I was so close to signing up for your
Patriot on recently, but lol. Not Anymore.
It goes Solo. You have immense support.
Thank you very much. Um, let's see.
Um, why didn't I get my $25 shadow
for my Dave Rubin monthly pudge?
If I go to Patrion a shout out to die
standing. You got a shout out right there.
How much is a shot? How much is a double
shot? You gave five bucks to ask that.
I'll do the next shot at 200. I can't,
I can't, I mean, what am I done now?
Three so far I haven't eaten all day.
I had,
I had a little salad and two
cups of bone broth. A Dave,
thanks for the amazing shout out sense.
Spend some time in po,
spent some time in Poland.
It was amazing.
I think Poland is actually going to be
on the next, uh, the next tour stops,
so hang tight on that. All right,
lots going on here. Um, guys,
I see a 200 sitting in here for drink.
Is that a new one?
Ah,
can I answer another question first?
Is there another? All right here.
Let me have a little water.
A little water.
How many of you watch Bandersnatch
by the way, if you guys,
did you guys watch a Netflix Black Mirror?
Bandersnatch statuary.
It's a choose your own adventure TV show.
I actually do feel like
we're kind of in that,
which is, which is pretty
freaking cool. Uh, Kevin Johnson,
were you a point guard on the
Phoenix Suns in the early 1990s?
Cause that's pretty awesome. If you
were also former mayor of Sacramento,
take a sip of water.
Dave, you're crazy high.
If you could please sign my mug before
they run out, went to the website.
It's properly swamped.
Best of luck with this.
It's just the site down
is a site down right now.
[inaudible] dot com slash
donate I hope not. Uh, 20 bucks.
You're not drunk. If you
can say brewery, tour,
brewery tour. You know, it's a tough one
to say. I want you to say this out loud.
If you're watching this Irish wristwatch,
can you say that? Play along
with me people. Irish wristwatch.
That's a tough one to say.
And if you could say that,
then you're really not drunk.
All right,
so apparently there's 200 bucks in here
saying drink. I need just a second.
What are we doing here? People?
I'm just raising funds. We're,
we're not going to do these fundraisers.
We will. I promise you. At least we will.
I, I said in the last thing, we're
not going to do them all year,
but I think we should probably do maybe,
maybe twice a year.
So I promise you we won't do one to
let's say June or July or summer or
something like that. Maybe the last
thing I do before I go off the grid, uh,
but we're just moving people
over from Patriot over today.
ruben.com/donate and you guys are
bored. We're, we're, we're going to be,
we're going to move forward.
We're going to keep building.
Things were all good,
but we're completely independent.
Thanks to you guys.
I don't have to join the network.
I don't have to do any of these other
crazy things. And I thank you for that.
And it's awesome. It's real.
This is seriously freaking
real. What can I tell ya?
Um,
I'm monthly on paypal,
but this stream is lit as fuck a f that's
how the kid say as fuck these days.
By the way. A good to know. Uh, um,
I know you're somewhat at least at
least somewhat interested in comics.
Are you familiar with the sun? So Neetu
series, remember to stay hydrated.
I don't know this the need two people.
How's my gulp sound on that?
Every now and again,
I have a drink on the show and people
say, Dave, you're allowed goalkeeper.
So I'm gonna just drink casually.
Let's just pretend.
I'll just pretend nobody's watching
and I'm going to drink casually.
How was that? Let me know in the comments
right down below. Okay, here we go.
I'm Dave, you've upstaged,
Elizabeth Pocahontas Warren.
She drank a beer in her video.
I think that was what the earlier
comment are meant to say. Yeah, I mean,
but that's like,
that's how stupid this thing is.
These people are trying to pretend to be
human. I drink a beer with my husband,
so I'm a real person. Look, oh my home,
and just happens to be here with my
laptop in the kitchen and he didn't know I
was going to live stream to millions
of people. It's like they're,
they're all just bullshit artists than
buffoons and stop paying attention to
them. But at the other level, you have
to be independent because it's your life.
So it's a little bit tough because these
people have on real ugly power on your
life, which is a problem late. A little
jellies, spoons. We have 25 minutes left.
Go to Dave Rubin dot compensation on it.
I got to get rid of some
of these freaking shirts.
I can't deal with the shirts anymore.
I have too many of them.
They're causing problems. Okay?
They're courting marital problems.
I need closet space people,
Dave rubin.com/donate 25 bucks a
month that you're getting a shirt,
50 bucks monthly. You're getting
the shirt, you're getting a mug.
I'm going to sign it for you
right now and then we're deleting.
Patrion I'm not extending this thing
after that. I promise you we're done.
I know there's 200 bucks sitting there
and super chat about the, about the shot.
All right, the next hundred.
If we got a hundred after this,
I'll do the freaking shot. I hope you're
happy. Let's go to the video tape.
Yeah.
Right now we have 1,745
I would say heathens,
ungodly heathens who have decided that
they do not want to stop paying us here
even though I don't want them to.
And I've sent several emails and I've
done live streams and tweeted about it and
the money keeps going up. I think we
went down to $9 last time. That was nice.
And here we go.
Jesus.
Fuck we did.
We just go up $1,500
we just went up $900
I can't
quit. You know
Dave,
Chris here,
just wanting to let you know that sword
and scale is donated about 500 on this
stream and you're awesome. And if you
need a product manager for me to platform,
Helen has my CV. Holla. Alright.
So, so Helen does have these things.
I'm not making it up. We do categorize
all of these things. A sword and scale.
I did not know, uh, about the podcast
before this, but I do know about it now.
He's been a huge supporter in, uh, in,
in getting the word out about Patrion.
I think he's the fifth
highest creator on Patrion.
He's planning on leaving quite patriotic.
Um, I don't, I don't know him personally.
I don't know. We've traded
a couple of messages. Um,
I don't know what he's
financial considerations are,
but people are trying to do what they
can and it is pretty freaking awesome. I,
I appreciate the support
brother and let's,
let's just keep trying to do what we can.
Uh,
I kept my patriot accounts simply because
I wanted to see what happens on the
patrion end when the accountant
we patronize is deleted or not.
That's fair.
Thank you for not giving me more money.
I think that's what you're saying.
But that's where you,
if you haven't deleted because
you want to just see what happens.
The moment I delete via the insider
thing that is happening on Patrion.
I do appreciate that. All
right. I'm giving shout outs.
Five bucks above on Dave ruby.com/donate
shirts 25 bucks above monthly and uh,
and uh,
mugs on that.
I will do another shot at 100 bucks
on super chat because you people are
seriously twisted. We just
went up $900 on patriot. I, I,
I don't know what to tell ya
there then. I can't, you know,
you've got to stop giving us money there
and this is not right or this is injust
I'm impressed.
I keep asking people to not do something
and they keep doing it. This is,
this is depression is the oppression
of the sith. It is back. Uh, all right,
I will be in Irvine,
California January 30th with a member
of the ITW at the Irvine Improv.
You can check Dave Ruby dot calculation
beds to check out that in case you can't
tell. I used to be on the radio. So I've
done a little bit of a, a little of this,
a little of that over
the years. Uh, all right,
who's jumping in on
superchat hundred bucks?
I'm going to do another shot at this
point. It's like, let's just do it.
You know what I mean?
Like let's just go down with the ship.
I'm going to end up with $4 billion on
Patrion. I'll be drunk as hell. I mean,
let's just roll with it. Um, okay. Um,
a lot of things here. Shout
out to John, Mike and Chrissie.
Thank you guys. I appreciate it. All
right, we got, it's seven Oh eight.
We got 22 minutes left.
I'm going to,
I'm going to click that
thing and if it's higher,
hmm.
I'm going to have to really
evaluate things. Aaron,
1,743 people have donated $10,853.
This is wrong.
This is not good.
We've got a $14 people.
I get it. I get it. It's all a joke.
Do all the joke to you people as I sit
here trying to delete this thing and you
give me your hard earned dollars just
to stick it to the man or something like
that. Um, I mean this is actually
hilarious. This is actually hilarious.
Like I give anyone that's given
any money on, they're like, we'll,
we'll clear out the account
before we delete, but like
legitimately hilarious. Like I, this
is not what I would've expected. Okay,
here we go.
FYI,
Jordan Peterson has deleted
his patrion page, but Bam,
22 minutes left people now.
20 minutes left. I have,
I can confirm we are
the people in the booth.
Jordan B.
Peterson of Canada has deleted
his patrion page. All right.
It's over. It's gone. It's done.
He's in Switzerland right now.
He deleted it from Switzerland.
Okay.
Try to grasp the gravity of the situation.
Shout out to Rory. Thank you right now.
Super Chat. You missed my shout
out for joining your side.
Punishment is another shot. You
sick? Twisted bastard. All right,
here we go.
Lord,
may the Lord have mercy.
I know all of us.
You don't know what's
wrong with you people
who,
Huh?
All right.
It's good to be here.
We're on Patrion.
I'd like to announce today that we're
rebooting our patrion on page and we want
to take as many donations
there as possible.
I feel like that's the
future of the Rubin report.
Joining third party sites that don't
care about free speech and seeing what
happens. Let's take a role in it. Ice, um,
thoughts on your comedian Buddy Owen,
Benjamin and him shitting on everyone.
Is He for real or he is just
part of the new comedy routine?
I honestly have no idea
what's going on with him.
I truly can't answer that in
any, in any sensible way. Uh,
we got 19 minutes left.
I can confirm that from Switzerland.
Jordan Peterson has deleted
his patriotic count.
I've taken I think five shots of
patrolling. I'm 42 years old people,
no 42 year olds should be drinking
five shots in neutron. Um,
okay.
I did three shows today before this
and the Internet has screwed me by
continually donating to the Patriot
account that I will be deleting in moment.
And a, I guess it's just the
sign of the Times. This is,
this is what it's all about.
We who
live in the Internet on this tube,
this youtube,
we're but
yeah.
Humble servants to you people.
But,
but really this is like a
choose your own adventure.
You're watching this right now
or controlling my destiny. It's,
it's extremely bizarre.
I'll try just realize what's very bizarre.
It's only seven 12 in the evening here.
I A,
I haven't had dinner but re but be in
18 minutes when I end this thing after I
clicked delete,
I'm going to be drunk.
I have several employees
and family members here.
None of them are going to be drunk cause
anyone drunk in there? Not yet. Not yet.
All right. They're not drunk
people. Very bizarre. Uh, okay.
Subscribe for 25 but change it
to 50 I didn't get another email.
Will I still be able to get a
mug? Keep up the good work. Yeah,
we'll make sure we'll see to
your name twice in there. Helen,
can you make sure we take care of
that for sure. We will deal with that.
All right. Ask me anything. People
ask me anything. We are deleting
patriot. All right, let's go. Here we go.
Let's do it right now.
We have 1,744 patrons despite at least
five emails despite three livestreams,
despite at least 20 tweets,
Instagram posts, everything.
Please stop giving me money.
Delete your page, your on account.
I don't want anything to do with
you people. Despite all of that. Uh,
we still have 1700 people
left and we have $10,957.
Here we go.
What do we, I think, ah, we went up.
Yeah,
we went down almost $900.
That's what I'm talking about.
People purge the money.
Let's get it out of Patrion.
They don't want our money.
They've got silicon valley
money. They've got VC money.
They don't need our buddy.
I love the fact that people at at paid
two and are watching this right now.
Like that's actually
pretty hilarious. Um, that,
that's the other thing about the internet.
The Internet is so stupid these days
that you have silicon valley people who
these people, all these social justice
warriors or or more so you have,
most of them are libertarians.
Actually,
I mean the secret of Silicon Valley
is that most of these people are
Libertarians because they believe that
they have ideas to create and that that
would give you a very liberty
minded view of the world.
They've become hostages to the SJW thing.
And because of that,
then there are around a bunch of
people who they actually don't like.
And I'm talking to all of these silicon
valley people that I know are watching
this right now. They become hostages to
all of these people. And then they're all,
they're all just a bunch of
sort of cowards, right? Know,
with all the soil and everything else.
They're there.
They can't really stand up for themselves.
So what happens is it just becomes a
self fulfilling prophecy that no one will
stand up for what they believe in.
So I have no doubt that there are plenty
of people at Patrion that completely
support what I'm doing here and, and
whatever. But it's like the fact,
think about it. Think about this. So
I joined Patriot in, in uh, Julie.
It was either June or May,
I think it was June of 2016 we've been
on there for two a half plus years.
We were basically making about 30 grand
a month there that the funded this whole
basically funded this entire company.
Um,
so you'd have to do the math on that two
and a half years of 30 grand a month.
Can someone do the math
on that 300, 600? I mean,
that's almost a million bucks over the
course of three years to find a Kokanee.
Now that sounds like a lot of money,
but when you're running a company
and paying a lot of people,
it's not a ton of money, but
think about like I've, I've been,
I've put a lot of money into this company.
Sam Harris put a lot of
money into this company,
Jordan Peters and put a lot of
money, this company, the fact that,
that nobody reached out to us,
you'd think that some
low level nobody would.
You would reach out and say, guys, we're,
we're having this little issue here,
but that's what, that's what's become
a problem with these companies now,
interestingly, I know that
the lefties will say, ah,
because you don't want regulation of
these companies and you think they can do
whatever they want to do. Yes, I do think
they can do whatever they want to do.
They can do whatever they want to do
and I can do whatever I want to do.
Freedom is messy,
but freedom is good.
Shout out to Ethan. Thank you
very much. $69 curious number.
I think you're onto something with this
whole. Pay me and I'll take a shot.
Fundraising. I like try it and see if
it works when you're not famous. Lol.
My famous,
I guess I'm famous.
It's weird that that's also a weird
thing because I'd had an od level of fame
where like clearly I guess
I'm famous at some level,
but like I go to whole
foods or I go like anywhere,
like I go to like the bowling alley or
like wherever it is that I go or I go to
like Petco or like people
recognize you are often,
I'll see people looking at me
and I'm like, ah, they'd like me.
I don't know if they or do they
think I'm a white supremacist.
So most of my day is wandering around
strange stores picking up food for my dog
going, ah, do they think
I'm a white supremacist?
Which should think how stupid this thing
all the whole thing is become. Yeah.
Um, next time you take a
shot, I'll make a PSAT,
make us sound like Anderson Cooper
and I'll donate $100. All right.
That's funny.
That might be the funniest thing
that's happened this whole time.
So if nobody watched
CNN on New Year's Eve,
like what kind of life do you have that
you'd watch CNN on New Year's Eve? Um,
but,
but you might've watched a clip of it
on Twitter and I saw a five second clip
where him and Andy Cohen, uh, and as a
Kubernetes going, they're taking shots.
And it's like,
that's the one night of the year that the
CNN people act get to act like humans,
but they can't really act like humans
because they've spent a year not acting
like a human. So how can they act like a
human on one night? That's a tough gig.
Uh, but so Anderson take a shot. He's
like, oh my God, it's so, all right.
You know what? Here's
what we'll do. 500 bucks.
I will do an Anderson Cooper impression
while taking a shot. It's gotta be 509.
I'm sorry,
the money's going up on Pedro.
And despite the fact
that I wanted to go down,
so here the rubber meets the road people.
I will do an impression
of Anderson Cooper.
Hey David, keep up the good work. I came
to America to be around people like you.
Instead I found free speech police,
hopefully people like you
help turn things around.
I'd love to know where you're from.
Uh,
can you do something that we can
figure out where this person is from?
I love story.
That's the other
thing. When I go into Uber's and cabs
and all these places that I go to,
whether it's in the states or not,
it was like everyone that I've met,
it's like everyone loves to be in
the West. They love to be in Canada.
They loved to be in the UK. They love
to be in America. It ain't that bad.
How much for a six shot daily,
you donate $5 and 69 cents.
Another interesting number.
Um,
I remember the time before you
had a patriot right after the ad.
Pocalypse it won't be that bad. We're
going to be all right here, right Jesse,
you're getting a Mug,
brother or sister Jessie could be a guy,
could be a girl,
but who am I to assign a gender to Jesse?
You know what I mean?
Huh.
Uh, and, and again, Jesse,
whatever gender you are,
I just want you to know, I think
you're great gender. You know, like
you're really a great guy or Gal,
you know Jesse,
great gal, great guy or Gal. Okay, here we
go. We've got 13 minutes left. By the way.
My phone is exploding right now.
I don't want to show all the,
the names of the people. Um,
but my phone is exploding,
which either means that I've ruined my
career tonight or we got some good shit
going on. I suspect it's the latter,
but you never know. Here we go.
We're going to hit refresh.
We have 1,444 people.
We've got 11 minutes remaining.
Clis if there is a lord in the university,
if any of this means anything,
let the number 10,079 go down.
We went up $900.
Huh?
All right.
You know what I love?
There is a set of a anonymous Twitter
accounts that are run by a journalist.
There's about, there's about
10 influential lefty, um,
anonymous accounts on Twitter that are
run by journalists and they think they're
really clever and I know they're watching
this waiting for me to say anything
off script or whatever.
Even though there's no script here,
they're waiting for me to just
say anything. That's anything.
And what they do is
they're anonymous Twitter.
There are journalists are
friends of journalists,
and what they do is they wait to clip
one thing and then they magically get
Huffpo or buzzfeed or vox,
which is the worst or any of these things
to quote what I say and say Ruben was
drunk and morale. I said
this. And it's like,
I know they're just sitting there
watching this and they couldn't get,
they couldn't get anyone to give them a
buck. And I'm literally asking people's,
you know,
giving me money right now.
Ah,
Oh, here we go. I can afford a
couple of months at 50 right now,
I hope gets me a cool sign
mug. Jesse is with Jesse
without the eye is male.
Now stop flirting with me. Oh,
Jessie, welcome back. All right,
so Jessie's going to get
the mug. Um, and you're
right. So it was j e s, s, e,
which I assumed was a male.
But these days with the way gender is so
fluid and the way just because you have
a penis, you might be uh, you know, you
can be a woman, you can be a decepticon,
whatever it is, sith Lord doesn't
matter. The point is, uh, you know,
we're just doing the best we can.
Okay.
Ladles and jellies boots.
We have s
we have nine minutes left.
We went up 900 bucks.
Huh?
The best part of this is,
so we really had,
the last couple days here
really have been insane.
So David had surgery as I mentioned
before. So David's not even part of this.
David's the executive producer of
the show who has run, if anything,
I do look remotely professional or
anything. Maybe, maybe not today,
but generally speaking, David has done
this. This is, this is him. He is,
he, he learned this from
scratch and has become,
I would say the best executive producer
probably in the business. And he,
he could not work these last couple
of days because he had, it was,
it was a minor sinus related surgery
but like he was knocked out on pain meds
and all sorts of stuff the last
couple of days. So we've, our, our,
my whole team is completely stepped up.
We,
we brought in some other people in my
brother and sister alive helped in a whole
bunch of people and uh,
the fact that we,
here we are this morning, I
said to David, I was like,
I hope that by the end of this like I
don't know how to get to these Patriot on
people.
I got it.
It's actually incredible and it's a little
sign of the times you're saying that
a certain amount of people just
donate to things and forget about it.
And I mean that, I don't mean that
judging them in a negative way.
I mean that is like,
it's actually kind of cool
if like someone's got a
couple of bucks and it's like
you fall, you get to something you
believe in and you just forget about it.
It's like, what are, what a luxury that
is. What a great thing that is. Um,
but I was like at the end of this,
like it would be so cool if the entire
livestream two hours we could watch this
number, drop, drop, drop, drop,
drop, drop, drop, drop, drop.
And we have not had that
happen. All right. 150
the bugs.
I think what you're doing is great and
I fully support your willingness to take
a stand and have the conversation
nobody else will have.
Thank you. You know what,
you didn't even ask me to take a shot,
but I'm feeling the flow. It's seven 23
this is patrolling ladles and jellies,
moons, ladles and jellies. Moons.
I want to give a shout out.
I hope my buddy.
So when I did stand up in New York for
12 years and I hope you guys will come
out and see me do stand up in the future,
um,
because people don't know that
part of me, uh, until they see it.
And then people are like, Holy Shit,
you're actually good at this. But,
which is actually more of a fun thing
cause people don't even pay to come to the
show and they don't even
know what to expect.
But there were two comics who I knew
that were great that I'm going to give a
public shout out to now that I don't even
know that you can find anything about
them online. The two best comics
that I ever knew in 12 years,
a standup in New York were
Bob Jergens and Mike Singer.
And I don't know that you can find
anything about them. Bobbed an actor now.
So I hope you can at
least find out about him.
I don't know what
happened to Mike. Um, but
Bob used to always get on stage and if
he was really struggling and he'd ham it
up and go come out ladles
and jellies spoons.
And I just thought it was the funniest
thing. So here we go. Yeah. Uh,
Bob and the old timers,
why,
why or not?
I look forward to the Huffington
post piece on this. Uh,
will you drink the whole bottle
if the number goes down to zero?
I mean that would genuinely
be the end of my life.
Which you sort of had this all should end,
right?
Like it should all end on a live stream.
Yeah. Alright. I, here's what I do.
It's,
it's seven 24 I'm going to do one check
right now and then at exactly seven 30
we're deleting this
motherfucker regardless of
what you sons of bitches have
done.
Here we go.
It's seven 25 I am clicking refresh
were taken. It's taken some
time. There was no change.
It did not change. Thank
you. That's all I ask.
It doesn't have to go down,
although I'd like it to go down,
but if we refer not to go. All
right, so that's where we're at.
That's the official number. Aaron, can
you throw back to that thing, Arthur,
this is the final official number.
I have 1,744 patrons.
Better donating $10,987 a month. I am.
I am. We'll come back here for a sec.
I am 100% joking aside and completely
acknowledging that the humor and the
trollish nature of the people
who have donated and last hour,
I am completely appreciative of all the
people that have done this and it's sort
of hilarious and many of them maybe will
see this video in a week or something.
People have lives too.
Um,
so I'm completely appreciative of anyone
that's been part of this thing and a
shout out to Patrick
and to Mike Right now.
I'm so appreciative of all that.
We're going to donate this
thing in five minutes.
And so let me get serious
for just a moment and then a,
and then we're going to lead this
thing or here. You know what?
I'll do these two quick questions. Come
on please give Anderson Cooper, c'mon,
please give.
And the Anderson Cooper and pressure.
And I was supposed to use the hundred
dollars to surprise to subscribe to Ben
Shapiro, but here I am. And
that's your bureau by the
way. It's his birthday today.
And because he would not bake me a
gay cake, I did not send him a cake.
I wanted to send them a cupcake,
but you know,
if you're not going to bake
me a cake for my gay wedding,
I'm not going to send you a birthday
cake so you get nothing. Shapiro.
I left patron as a support,
the first amendment and they silence
quite a few people. How do I attain a Mug?
You can get a mug if you
go to Dave ruben.com/donate
and you donate $50 a month
and you can cancel whenever you want,
but if you donate $50 a month to start,
we'll send you a mug. I shouldn't
have said that because you know,
we want you to obviously keep donating,
but it is what it is.
Ladies and gentlemen, we have
three minutes left. Love drunk.
Dave can't believe you didn't get
sick on camera. You're a trooper
old school.
You know what I'm saying?
Old School. All right,
we got two minutes left.
I just want to say really
this has been a pleasure.
There's a huge part of me that wants
to keep this going right now. Um,
but I know I probably should
not. And I know that, that my,
my dedicated staff has lives.
Some of them might want
to get laid tonight or do
whatever they do in their own
lives.
So for me to sit here and
continue this insanity would be,
would be selfish and I
don't want to do that.
So I've got about two minutes
left more than anything else.
I genuinely want to thank you guys.
Anyone that forget anyone that's donated,
knew for a second for any of you that
have donated over the last two and a half
years. The day that we
started the patriotic thing
and I, and I quit my job at,
or a TV and my executive producer and
my director quit with me on a lark.
It truly was a lark.
We did not know what was going to happen.
And I said to them the
night before, I said, I,
if I may have screwed up all of our lives,
like I had worked so hard to get
something and I quitted network so that we
could do something.
Um,
we didn't know what was going to
happen in the next morning within it,
within a half hour.
We knew we were going to be okay
and we've been okay ever since then.
And there has been ups,
there have been downs,
the twists and turns that come
along the way. Um, but I've really,
I truly, I have genuinely tried to do the
best thing that I could along the road.
I've made mistakes.
I'm not perfect.
I am open to the same criticism that
Edinburgh, everyone else is open to.
Um, but I promised you guys,
this is just the beginning.
It's just the beginning again,
which is weird that there's something
about life in that at the beginning can
keep happening if you keep doing
something real. I, I dunno what that is,
but I actually think it is something
and I'll keep trying to do it the best I
can. Um, so I thank you guys
for that. Um, well let's see.
I will ask,
I will answer one more question and then
it's seven 29 and we're going to delete
this bitch ass motherfucker
tag team wrestling match,
Huh?
Uh Huh.
Tag team wrestling match.
Ben Shapiro and Jordan Peterson,
verse Dave Rubin and Eric
Weinstein who would win.
Okay.
I run,
I think this one through.
And I love the fact that this is the
last thing then I'm going to do before I
cancel this thing and a shout
out to Michael Real quick.
Shapiro and Peters and now Dan Shapiro.
[inaudible] Shapiro,
small by Shapiro.
Fast.
He'll get you.
Okay,
now Peterson's got that long
reach and he's got quick hands.
So you've got quick hands and you got
somebody quick. So this is the last speed.
Dave Rubin and Eric Lyons name.
I'll do Ruben last.
That guy's good Weinstein.
Now he can think it through.
He can think of through and he's got
big hair so he could use his hair as a
weapon. So now you're looking
at our hair weapons situation.
I could also envision a situation
where Eric's just gonna plow through a
Weinstein.
You know what I mean?
Like they're going to get face to face
and Shapiro was going to be moving fast,
but Eric's just gonna plow
through. Now. You got Ruben?
Yeah,
I, I, you know, he's the
most fit of the group.
Ladies and gentleman,
I'm going to delete Patriot right now.
I'm going to leave that
decision of that question,
which is an extremely important question,
which is about the battle of ideas
and the regressive left and all of it.
I'm going to leave that, I'm going to
set that down and I'm going to delete.
Patria my phone is exploding.
My phone is on fire.
I can't show you all of this.
My phone is actually melting
through the table right now.
I have a time bomb sitting with
me. It's time to delete. Patrion
um, in case it's not clear. Thank you
guys. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Whether you,
whether you donate it on Patrion I in
the past or that you donate now and even
if you didn't donate, if you, I don't
care. Truly we're going to be okay.
And if you were any part of this part
of the silliness that we've done for the
last two and a half hours,
um,
this is as good as it gets.
This really is as good as you get as far
as anything I know on this universe is
as good as it gets.
So I'm going to hit refresh on this thing
one more time and then you're going to
watch me delete this. So here we go. So
right now after two and a half hours,
we have more money than we started with
and I think more patrons. No, no, no.
Maybe we lost patrons, but we have more
money. But here we go. I'm refreshing.
Okay, so we did actually go down to our
and throw to me one more time. Okay.
So we did actually go down.
So thank you.
I don't know what happened
here and I don't know why.
I guess all of these people like it
just is what it is. It is what it is.
It's all good guys. Thank
you. Really, really,
I wish I could say this in a way that
could possibly be more genuinely felt that
I'm possibly saying it right now with
genuinely, genuinely, genuinely thank you.
That is all I can say.
And uh,
this is just the beginning.
So now I'm going to click delete.
Uh, so I think there's a delete here
somewhere. So I'm going to click settings.
We're doing it live. Fuck
it. We're doing alive.
I'm clicking account.
Nope.
Now I may have to move here for it just
to say it physically because I got to
scroll. I know there's a way to scroll
without doing it the way I do it.
Old School. But I do it. Old
School disabled my account.
Here we go guys. This is it. Careful.
This will permanently
disable your account.
You won't be able to log in again and
after you do this, oh wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Actually I should do one thing just to
be clear in case that's actually true.
I don't want them stealing the
money that you guys donated,
even though I didn't want you
to donate money. So let's do it.
Let's just knock that out real quick.
Um,
payout preferences.
So
in the course of the last two and a half
hours where I've tried to lose money on
this thing,
you guys donated $1,452 and 89 cents.
So thank you. You freaks. So
we're going to send that, oops.
Don't look at that, Huh?
That's my old Gmail.
Don't want to see that. Okay. All right,
so I have nothing in
my patriotic right now.
And now I'm going to click settings.
Please don't email me.
I have, you know, other things
going on. Um, okay, so setting
FedEx. All right. All right. Settle
down. Oop, I, quick messages. No,
we don't want to see that.
Okay. Ignore that. Sorry.
Oh Lord.
Settings. No. Ow. Cricket counts. W what?
The right
account on the left
to the right to the right. Oh, God isn't
not a song. Doesn't Beyonce do that? Oh,
that's to the left.
What?
Oh, account. There we
go. All right. All right.
Here we go.
This is it ladies and gentlemen.
Drum roll please.
[inaudible]
Oh God, please enter your password. Wait,
I don't know the password.
Okay.
Yeah.
Do if someone's going to get
the password. All right, Aaron,
please come back to camera one.
I'm going to Mosey on in.
I don't know the password.
It could be anything for two nine one six,
eight,
four a, B, c, d, e, f, g,
some combination thereof.
No idea. Uh, I guess
I'll, in the moment we're,
we're looking for the password and we
have it in a very secure place. Oh,
I've got a team member.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no. What
are you stupid and you can't say.
Yeah.
That was literally the dumbest thing
that has ever happened in the history of
the Internet.
You got to write it down.
You idiot.
Can you tell me the password
that was, that was, that was,
that was the beautiful ending
to this whole thing. All right.
Now I'm going to have to go back
to this thing. We got the password.
This is true lunacy. I guess I could
do another shot. Oh, I'm waiting.
Hmm.
Oh, it's being written down. All right.
I'm being handed the piece of paper
off camera. Thank you.
I've been handed the paper,
but damn, that's the password.
Little Shit. Alright,
here we go. Enter Password.
Submit. Oh, password.
Okay, good. Here's what
I'm gonna do for a second.
I'm just going to get in front of the
camera so I can just knock this thing out.
So here we go.
Okay.
I have placed the password in the Patrion.
I am deleting and I remember guys,
I have about 10,000 bucks a month that
I could just repeat and it clearly
wouldn't go anywhere and I keep getting
this money. Zippity damn do. Here we go.
Submit.
Okay.
To keep your scarf for God's sakes.
There's my email address again,
my private one to keep your account safe.
We've sent you an email at blah, blah,
Blah with the linkedin. Disable
your account. Okay. Hold
that thought. Guys. This is,
we've entered, we've entered. True.
Yeah. Something or other. Aaron,
maybe you want to go to the other
camera is my head even in the camera.
All right. Hey everybody. How are you?
Dave Rubin trying to delete
my patriotic camp. Okay.
Okay. We're sorry. We're all
right. Aaron. Here we go.
We're sorry to see it go.
You're receiving this email because
you've requested disable your account in
account settings.
If you didn't request this,
please contact patriots support to
ensure the security of their can.
I would email them and ask them their
thoughts about a freedom of speech,
but it's a little late for that. If
you do want a date, sable your account,
simply click on the disabled.
My account button below your account will
be permanently disabled and you won't
be able to log into your patron
account using this user name password.
It's up to you with the account.
Thanks for checking out.
Patrion you will be missed in a five four,
three,
two.
Oh, for God's sakes, there's
another freaking button.
Are you sure you want to
disable your patrion account?
This action cannot be reversed. Let's
keep it going for six more hours. No,
here we go.
Oh, you've got to be fucking
kidding me. There was a problem.
Disabling your account.
You disabled link may have expired.
Please visit your account
settings and try. Unbelievable.
Unbelievable. You gotta be kidding
me. You gotta be kidding me.
Busy your account settings. All right,
hang tight. People go to account settings.
Let's try that again.
You gotta be kidding me?
Disabled my account.
I'm putting the password in again.
Jesus Christ.
Hold on.
We sent your email. All right, well now
that you all have my private emails it,
that's wonderful.
We'll be changing that one soon.
Enough confirmation needed.
Got It.
Zero minutes ago.
We're sorry to see you
go disabled my account.
Yes.
Disabled my account.
Aaron,
come back to the one shot.
Okay.
Yeah,
I'll be on patrion forever.
All right.
I don't know what the
hell is going on here.
Uh,
I promise you I will delete this
fucking thing whenever I can.
This is, this is actually a perfect
ending to this whole story, right?
Like this is the way these companies
operate. If I emailed this,
these people tomorrow,
they would not respond to me.
I'd have to publicly shame them on Twitter
like I do with youtube all the time.
I wouldn't be able to get in touch with
the person, all of these stupid things.
Um, all right, let's not worry about it.
I think you guys got the point. I mean,
what are ridiculously anticlimactic yet
totally fitting ending to all of this.
Um, I would try one more time, but I think
you guys, we illustrated the point here,
so is what it is.
Um,
so on that moat, uh, on that note, um,
I genuinely have nothing but
thanks for you guys. That's it.
I got nothing but thanks. Thank you
guys. Thank you for my team that,
that helped me make this
whole thing happen today. And,
and since we started this whole operation,
uh,
I thank everybody that was
part of this craziness today,
whether it was on super chat or
Patrion or wherever it was. Um,
yeah,
I got,
I got a bottle of Patrona and a patriotic
count I can't get rid of and there in
lies and incredible story,
uh,
which will probably make it into my
book that I'm writing right now. So, uh,
you guys saw it happen live so,
so genuinely thank you and
Yah,
wait a minute. We will wait.
Jordan deleted his account
so Jordan was able to lead an
account and I can delete my account.
Yeah. Alright. Alright,
I'm deleting this account.
Please never come back to the
patrion.com/rubin report page. Um,
fight for what you believe in, even if
it's not the things that I believe in,
but fight for them honestly
and forthrightly. Fourth,
rightly and uh,
and decently,
and understand that you're supposed
to live in a country with people that
disagree with you.
We'll keep having these conversations.
This really is just the beginning.
Jordan and I are going
to build something great.
There's all sorts of steps in the,
along the road to make this happen.
I think you got the point already
and, and thank you. And uh,
I have to pee
good night.